but first I'd ask you all to rise and
join Representative Steven Kennedy as he
leads us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
Al
stes for
all okay on tap for today this morning
we have two public
hearings and these will be the final two
public
hearings for science technology and
energy for this
year the first one is on hb1 1623 FN
relative to State energy policy the
second is HB
1487 relative to the health effects of
5G
technology we will then take a lunch
break and we'll return at
1:30 for a work session on six
bills HP 1697 FN suspending New
Hampshire's participation in emissions
and reduction credit programs for a
period of two years HB 1700 FN
prohibiting the intentional release of
polluting emissions including cloud
seating weather
modification excessive electromagnetic
radio frequency and microwave radiation
and making penalties for violation of
such
prohibition HB 1036 relative to the
assessment of cost effectiveness of
effectiveness of the system benefits
charge hb178 relative to first responder
organization access to wireless tower
collocation HB 1465 relative to studies
of nuclear energy
Technologies and finally HB
1472 relative to rebates of Energy
Efficiency funds for electric
vehicles and then at 3:00 we will have
executive session on the bills that I
just U read about with regard to the
work session so we'll have an executive
session on those same Bills starting at
3:00
so once we have a a a brief resit here
to shuffle chairs we'll begin our first
public
hearing
okay I declare the uh public hearing to
um HB
1623 open representative oose introduces
the
Bill thank you Mr Vice chairman and good
morning fellow colleagues for the record
representative Michael
V representing Rockingham District 5 the
town of eeping
and I'm here this morning to introduce
House Bill 1623 FN relative to State
energy
policy so about 140 years ago Thomas
Edison created the first Power
Generation Plant on Pearl Street in New
York City a Coal Fired Generation Plant
that
began the electrification
era the past 40 years have 140 years
rather have led to
essentially some of the most significant
achievements in the history of
civilization and
electricity has been largely responsible
for that electricity today is the
lifeblood of modern
civilization some people have just
described the electricity grid as the
greatest machine that's ever been
built it's complex it's huge has many
many moving
parts and keeping it
running reliably and
stably with stability is an incredible
task a complex
task but to protect our way of life we
have to
safeguard our electrical
grid the reliability of our grid relies
on is comprised of two components one is
capacity meeting demand generating
enough electricity to meet the
demand but the other is stability and
stability has some tech technical ter
some technical components and some
non-technical
components one of the technical
components is frequency maintaining
frequency of the power
system grid frequency refers to the rate
at which alternating current oscillates
and it's typically measured in
hertz and deviation from the standard
frequency can have significant
consequences including potential damage
to equipment and disruptions in the
operation of electrical devices that
damage can be
significant if the grid were to go
down in such a way that major components
of grid infrastructure were damaged it
could take months some even say years to
restore that
infrastructure and in the
interim people will die
so the reliability and the stability of
our
grid is a key to our
continued life enjoyment of
life and our civilization I
think that's a kind of a preamble to
explain why I've introduced or why I am
introducing house bill
1623 I call
this colloquially the New Hampshire
energy independent acts Independence
act what does this bill
do it acknowledges the responsibility of
the state and guaranteeing the health of
our citizens by protecting our supply of
electrical
power we can't live without it simple as
that and because we live in a regional
grid there's not a lot we can do at the
state level to protect our electricity
Supply but we can do some
things this bill asserts the
Constitutional 10th Amendment
sovereignty of New Hampshire regarding
non- congressionally mandated closure of
a power Generating
Station let's the state take some action
if that were to
happen this gives the state some
leverage to oppose regulatory
overreach this bill also establishes
that market forces should drive the
governance of
state power
delivery
now in the preamble to the bill on page
one the findings of the bill state that
the health the
safety and the welfare of the citizens
of New
Hampshire are at stake
here it is our responsibility state
representatives to do whatever we can to
protect that Health that safety and that
welfare
and as I indicated in my
Preamble electricity is the lifeblood of
this
civilization and if we're not doing
everything we can to protect
it we're
not delivering on the Mandate of our
elected office to protect the health
safety and Welfare of our state's
citizens so I believe that as line 13 of
the states that the state has a duty to
defend the production and supply of
affordable reliable dispatchable and
secure energy from external regulatory
interference and that's one of the
reasons that I submitted this
bill but in addition to the protections
that it offers to the possibility that a
significant power generation Source
could be prematurely shut down the bill
also puts into
statute some important con
Concepts Concepts such as allowing
Market forces to drive prudent use of
energy
resources to prescribe that government
intervention should be limited narrow
and necessary for a specific policy
goal
to state emphatically
that New Hampshire should
pursue goals like energy conservation
and efficiency according to Market
principles and without New Hampshire
shall maintain an environment that
allows for accurate Market signals while
balancing low consumer prices price
stability and energy
reliability and the bill goes on to say
that New Hampshire shall promote the use
of clean energy resources or
sources but that it should
consider the entire life cycle of that
energy
resource now there is a f fiscal note
attached to the uh bill which indicates
that
the department of energy and the Public
Utilities
Commission might be incurring some costs
if
the section three of the bill was
ever uh required to be used to a section
two of the bill rather required to be
used to
um deal with an electricity generator
that's being prematurely forced to
retire that uh is a concern worth
discussing and I will probably discuss
that with the department at a
before sometime before exec session to
see if there's a way we can address that
issue before we go to exec session so I
think I've lined laid out the uh the
bill as I intended it what I intended it
for
it may not may not be the most elegant
template for a bill to do something to
help us protect our energy
resources but as the govern pointed out
just yesterday or the day before the
States created the Federal Government
the federal government didn't create the
states so the most important part of
this legislation is to assert our state
sovereignty to do whatever we can to
protect the citizens who live here the
citizens who elected us to this
office this may not not be the most
elegant template as my good friend uh
from Lebanon will recall computer
programmers when they create or design
an algorithm they strive for
Elegance
efficiency uh speed Etc this may not be
the most elegant template for doing
something about protecting our health
and the safety of our citizens but I
like its simplicity and I like its
assertion of our state
sovereignty so with that I'll be happy
to answer questions if I can and then
listen to what I'm sure will be a
spirited uh
response uh thank you representative
I'll take the first question just for
administrative reasons on page two line
16 and in difference to what you said
yesterday uh when you talk about clean
energy would you all also say that that
should be read as non-carbon generating
energy or something to the effect that
we spoke about
yesterday you mean non-carbon dioxide
emitting right generation yeah yes
absolutely
okay as uh I discussed yesterday there
is no definition and statute anywhere of
what clean clean energy is and in fact
it's a term that's been used used so
frequently that it probably has as many
meanings today as people want to ascribe
to it it it's come become kind of an
imprecise term so we probably should use
terms like non CO2 emitting sources
you're
right representative
paral thank you chair Thomas and thank
you uh representative o for your test
Tony today I appreciate it hope I got
that right um go picking up on uh
um the last
question I am seeing that use of clean
energy sources by considering the
emissions throughout the entire life
cycle clean energy carbon free energy
whatever you want to call it does this
put an extra burden upon those what are
typically called renewable sources while
letting uh fossil fuel
sources uh not taking them into the same
account I wouldn't think so I think we
should be taking into account for
everything we
build all the expenses that we're going
to recur to build
it and
if emissions of carbon dioxide are
considered an
expense then we would have to take that
into account for everything I would
think representative
rals thank you Mr Vice chairman um and
thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question um as you noted in your opening
remarks um the state of New
Hampshire gets its energy its
electricity as part of a
regional power
grid governed
by
Regional um Regional
bodies um and I would note that these
Regional bodies and
the power generation facilities
that are governed
by uh the bodies the regional grid are
all privately owned
um did you have in mind when you're
writing this bill did you have in mind
the situation uh that we've referenced a
couple times in the committee here uh
about the retirement of the Mystic River
Power Station uh in Boston is that what
is sort of
motivating this piece of
legislation no this uh piece of
legislation is focused on what few
generation sources are right here in New
Hampshire such as cabber nuclear power
station the um gas fired power plant in
London der the Burgess biopower plant up
in
Berlin uh those kinds of resources that
are located in the state right follow up
follow up but um again noting that all
of
those generating assets
are privately owned
facilities and and you make reference in
the legislation to you know Market
forces I guess I'm curious as to what is
contemplated
um what you're contemplating this giving
the State the power to sort of take
control or override um a a private
entity a business's decision
to you know potentially close a a power
plant are you contemplating that the
state of New Hampshire would step in
and I don't know take ownership or or
prevent uh something from happening with
one of these assets I guess I'm no
puzzle if you look at page two of the
bill line 18 it says an electricity
generator that receiv receives notice of
any Federal Regulation that may result
in the forced retirement of the
generator's
facility shall and then at that point uh
it goes on to explain what a generator
can do to seek
relief so no I'm not saying that if a
private company that that owns a
generation plant for business reasons
decides it has to shut that plant down
that's perfectly within its rights to do
that that's apparently what's going to
be happening with Mystic station that
you mentioned earlier what I'm
specifically concerned about here is
that uh regulation that is not
authorized by
specific congressionally passed law
could force a premature primate
premature retirement of
a power generation facility
and this gives the state an Avenue to
deal with that if it should
happen Okay thank you representative
bardy thank you Mr Vice chair uh so
um understanding what you just said uh
are the plants in Bow as well as
Portsmouth the sheller
facility uh potential
uh entities that are under some kind of
non- congressional uh
oversight forcing potential shutdown or
termination of
activities I'm not aware of any that are
currently happening but they would be
potential targets as would any other n
uh Generating Station here in the
state representative
Ms thank you Mr Vice chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
I I I I just want to follow up on a on a
on a comment you made um previously in
response to representative reels about
external regulatory authorities just I'm
trying to understand a little bit better
what that is I what I heard you say was
that it was it would be a body that was
not specifically authorized by by by
Congress can you give me some examples
of that because you I'm thinking for
example of you know like isoo England I
mean I'm I'm guessing I I'm I'm not sure
but I assume that that somehow comes
under you know Authority granted by
Congress to FK and and other entities so
what what spec what spefic specific
external regulatory authorities do you
have in
mind so you're right ISO New England
falls under the federal power act which
is implemented by
furk however sometimes regulatory
agencies for example the
EPA promulgate regulations that are not
specifically authorized by an act of
Congress
and frequently the EPA gets taken to
court over regulations that it
has
established that are not directly
authorized by an act of Congress and the
courts then decide is that
constitutional or is that a violation of
the Constitution there is one pending
before The Supreme Court right now uh
concerning
a doctrine that goes back to 19 1984
called the
Chevron uh difference Doctrine and to me
that's a classic example
of federal regulatory overreach that a
state like New Hampshire exercising its
Sovereign rights ought to be able to
challenge if that if those regulations
are going to negatively impinge on the
health safety and Welfare of New
Hampshire citizens
followup yes quickly so so on the you
know I'm glad you brought up the chevron
case um so in that instance um um you
know
somebody I can't remember who the
plaintiffs were but they took they went
to court Supreme Court made a ruling
that um the agencies did have the
authority under the Constitution so um
shouldn't New Hampshire then follow that
Court ruling because it's it was
determined to be
constitutional or I I guess I wanted to
make sure you weren't suggesting that
even if the Supreme Court made a ruling
that something was constitutional New
Hampshire should still pursue a Avenue
that goes counter to that
ruling no you are correct I wouldn't uh
assert that but in the case of the
Chevron Doctrine case that's pending
before The Supreme Court it has not been
decided yet
and if the Supreme Court does
decide as some observers are suspecting
that it will set
aside the precedent of the Chevron
difference Doctrine then it will be more
it will be easier for individuals who
are who are harmed by regulatory
overreach to
find uh redress in in the courts for
that kind of
behavior uh I'd like to remind before we
move on here we have five other speakers
on this topic uh time being what it is
and among those speakers are clean
energy new hampt Department of energy
New England power generator uh
conservation law so if you have any
questions that would be better presented
to those speakers I would suggest that
we hold them for that with that said uh
I'll call on representative Bernardi for
his question thank you Mr Vice chair so
uh uh non- Congressional uh uh
authorized action could also include uh
executive uh Decisions by the the
president that are not uh based in any
uh particular statutory uh uh approvals
most definitely those are some of the
more dangerous um acttiv activities that
need to be
challenged representative
McGee thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you Mr chairman um so to get back to the
bill one of the things that concerned me
when I saw this bill is that it seeks to
repeal uh the the statutory definition
of New Hampshire energy policy under 378
37 colon 37 and that was a um an aspect
of the leas cost integrated resource
planning um RSA that was saved last year
during the Senate hearings on House Bill
281 folks realized that that was on the
chopping block and said we need to save
that definition and that definition
which is quite brief says the general
court declares that it shall be the
energy policy of this state to meet the
energy needs of its citizens and
businesses of the state at thecal lest
reasonable cost while providing for the
reliability and diversity of energy
sources to maximize the use of
costeffective Energy Efficiency and
other demand side resources and to
protect the safety and health of the
citizens the physical environment of the
state and the future supplies of
resources with consideration to the
financial stability of the state's
utilities it was discussed in that
Senate hearing that this was a um a a
well-defined and
suitable uh level of New Hampshire
energy policy in terms of a definitional
framework the issue that I have with the
bill is that when it redefines that
framework it is it is taking the protect
the safety and health of the citizens
and sort of redefining the way we
approach that and um it's it the way to
my reading it looks like what it's
saying is we need to um be able to
provide fossil
fuel electric generation in order to
protect the safety of the citizens of
the state um which I think is is at odds
with a lot of the other um policy
decisions that have been made over the
past 20 years so I'm just trying to
figure out whether we're moving
backwards in putting that in removing
language that is more um inclusive of
the types of policies that we've been
moving towards to sort of put the thumb
on the scale of
um of energy sources that we have been
moving away
from well I didn't hear a question there
but I'll react to your statement by
saying
that this legislation attempts to deal
with
reality the reality is that 80% of the
world's energy comes from fossil
fuels today and it has been this way for
the last 20 25
years in spite of the fact that we spent
7 trillion dollar to try to replace
fossil fuels with something
else and we haven't
succeeded because the replacement
technology just isn't up to the
task so I think it's time that we start
recognizing
that this is our
future we might not love it we might not
think it's perfect but this is our
future until something better comes
along now we don't want to erect
barriers to the possibility that
something better will come
along but at the same time we have to
acknowledge that we're not there yet it
it's it's maybe an unpleasant isn't
thing to have to acknowledge but it is
reality um May I follow up one follow up
yeah I I think uh I understand what
you're saying and I understand where
you're coming from
I I would beg to differ on the
definition of of the safety uh of the
citizens I think that's where we have
the difference of opinion is that the
safety of the citizens representative
excuse me there's not a debate is is
your a question there
yeah okay yeah um the safety of the
citizens in terms of our energy policy
legislation that's been in
statute is regards to lowering emissions
it's it's in regards to the threat that
is posed from a warming
atmosphere so that's we're we're
changing that definition to mean
something
else and that's that's what I'm asking
you about I'm saying is that is that the
purpose of the bill
since you just asked the same question
or made the same statement twice I'll
just repeat my response which is this
bill is asking us to confront our
reality okay I think we've answered
asked enough questions uh from Mr
representative I would like to move on
we have five other speakers here and if
you have questions you can ask them as
well we're starting to go circular
around the same the same information so
thank you representative o and I'm going
to call on Mr Sam Evans Brown from clean
energy New
Hampshire uh to give us your impression
of this
bill thank you Mr chair
uh I can I can wait okay uh for the
record uh Sam Evans Brown executive
director of clean energy New Hampshire I
will say Mr chair I always appreciate
how you call me Mr Sam Evans Brown makes
me feel very respected so always
something I appreciate when I get called
up to the Lector in
here um so I thought I'd just start by
reading into the into the uh uh the
record what the state current energy
policy declaration is it says the
general court declares that it shall be
the energy policy of the state to meet
the energy needs of the citizens and
businesses of the state at the lowest
reasonable cost which this statute will
repeal that phrase um while providing
for the reliability and diversity of
energy sources to maximize the use of
cost-effective Energy Efficiency and
other demands side resources and to
protect the health and safety of the
citizens the physical environment of the
state and the future supplies of
Resources with consideration of the
financial stability of the state's
utilities I see that as a very simple
declarative and adequate statement that
is going to be repealed if this bill
were to be uh adopted um in particular
there are a number of areas in this
statute that I find concerning that I'd
love to raise with the committee um but
since the the we have been told that
this bill is about reality um I'd also
like to uh talk about another aspect of
the reality that is confronting Us in
the state which is that currently uh
north of
99% of the resources that are proposed
that are part of the iso New England
interconnection queue are either wind
solar or batteries
99% so there there are vanishingly few
projects that are actually being
proposed by people who have access to
Capital that uh that are fossil fueled
resources there's something on the
neighborhood of 180 megaw of gas turbine
imp improvements that are part of that
interconnection que and so my concern
with this language is that what it is is
a giant flashing warning sign to any
developer that they shouldn't try to
build things in New Hampshire and that
they should take the capital that they
have and bring it to other states that
are more friendly to the types of
resources that are that are being
deployed um the question of why are
these resources being deployed is a
really important one and I would argue
it's because the market has spoken when
you look at levelized cost of energy
wind and solar are the cheapest resource
that you can deploy and if we were to
put into statute language that makes uh
a a statement such as the one that
appears
on um page one line 25 with an EMP
emphasis on dispatchable resources
without regard of whether
dispatchability actually uh creates rate
payer savings um I think that we're
leaving a lot of rate payer benefit on
the table um I'd like to talk about a
couple of programs that I think would uh
confront difficulty in uh achieving
regulatory approval if this was the
energy policy that is on the books um so
for instance the New Hampshire saves
three-year plan which uh currently
creates is forecast to create $675
Million worth of rate pay or benefit I
think would face struggle getting
through the regulatory process with a
statement like the one that appears
online on page two uh that New Hampshire
Shel pursue pursue energy conservation
and efficiency according to Market
principles and without government
subsidies let's take a step back and
remember why New Hampshire saves exists
which is that it's broadly recognized
that Energy Efficiency is an area that
is a market failure in which uh uh folks
who make the decisions about about their
their energy their energy Investments
frequently lack the information required
struggle to understand the cost benefit
um struggle to have the capital required
to to uh to invest in these
cost-effective measures um and so for
decades despite the fact that these are
cost-effective as as evidenced by the
large rate payer benefit that that acrs
from the New Hampshire saves plan we
have struggled to get folks to to invest
in these measures of their own accord
that is a market failure and what are we
saying when we say that we want to
pursue Energy Efficiency strictly by
market principles it's essentially
saying let's not pursue uh those those
cost-effective uh Investments um
similarly Unitil just had approved a 5
megawatt solar array it's a
utility-owned solar array in Kingston
it's uh forecast to to generate $2
million worth of rate paay benefits by
2035 once it's up and running um the
emphasis on dispatchability might say
that we're not going to invest in that
type of of infrastructure regardless of
the rate payer benefit that's accured by
uh this acing from it um New Hampshire
is not you to to address a question that
was asked earlier we are not the entity
that ensures the reliability of the
electric grid that is ISO New England
that is their federally uh that is their
federally federally delegated Duty
because of the complexity of the the New
England grid and the fact that it
crosses State boundaries so it is not up
to us to ensure frequency uh reliability
that's what the iso is for and I think
putting into in language into State
Statute that suggests that that we're
trying to Eclipse that Authority from
ISO New England is is unnecessary and
and again going back to the the simple
and elegant definition that we already
have in statute I would argue the
language is already a little bit there
that says that we want to make sure that
health and safety are are uh are ured
for our
citizens um and and lastly I I I take I
take exception as well to uh line 16 on
page two that uh that when we are
promoting the use of clean energy
resources by ensuring the life cycle uh
of of that energy resource it is
entirely unclear to me why we are only
considering the life cycle of just clean
energy resources I actually do think
that life cycle accounting is a very
important tool that we should be taking
uh taking into account for whatever
energy choice we make but uh it it seems
like a double standard that that would
only be applied to a single type of
resource in particular the mining burden
associated with fossil fuel extraction
is is quite intense and if you'll have
ever talked to folks who live um outside
of the you know the Eagle Ford Shale in
Texas and talk about the Benzene
emissions that come from those
facilities they'll they'll tell you that
there's burdens there as well um and and
so uh I think generally speaking I
appreciate the attempt to uh to try to
flesh out what the state's energy policy
is um I would argue that if uh this is
something that the general court wants
to uh Embark upon it should be done so
in in you know a more uh bipartisan way
that that solicits feedback from lots of
individuals and puts into puts into
place something that provides regulatory
certainty for our utilities as opposed
to um as opposed to this language so
with that I'll
pause thank you questions representative
Thomas thank you um I wasn't able to
asked the prime sponsor so I guess I'll
ask you on uh line three page two it
talks about removing regulatory barriers
to Innovation to ensure that the state
can procure affordable reliable and
secure energy resources it doesn't say
removing some it says removing
regulatory barriers so my question to
you is do you see this as an attempt to
decouple New Hampshire from the United
States energy program Andor um ISO New
England um H uh well I'm I'm uh I know
you were hoping to ask the prime sponsor
that question so I will not I will not
speculate what the intention was there I
I personally actually see that line as
as less problematic than other pieces of
this legislation I would agree that
there are regulatory barriers to
Innovation um that that we could address
here in the state in terms of how the
Public Utilities Commission approaches
uh investments in the energy system and
and in particular um opening up uh
distribution system improvements uh to
to uh investments from third parties
which I think is an area that that's
quite Prime for Innovation um so uh
again I i' prefer not to speculate as to
what that is about followup
followup thank you um and just my second
question to the prime sponsor you've
sort of covered it but I just want
confirmation on on line nine that that
statement without state government
subsidies that would essentially kill NH
saves correct uh again it to me it is
actually un it is it is a matter of
substantial debate as to whether the
system benefits charge is indeed a
subsidy I would argue that that is a a
approved investment in a demand side
Resource as opposed to a subsidy uh I
know that opponents to the New Hampshire
saves program have have attempted to
characterize it as a subsidy but I would
reject that character a um I would be
concerned that that uh some Regulators
might use that language in order to
attempt to dismantle pieces of our of
our rate pair funded Energy Efficiency
program thank you very
much representative leki uh thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you Mr Brown um
would we seem to be wrestling with the
concept of um you know the reliability
of Renewables and dispatchability and
would you um be in favor of perhaps when
people are doing industrial scale U
Renewables window power solar um that
they be a mandate that they have some
amount of that capacity be 24 hours of
backup so that they really could be
dispatchable uh I would not uh be in
favor of that specific mandate that you
just put in place I would argue that we
are actually going to be seeing much
more coupled storage uh with renewable
energy variable Renewables uh going
forward because of Market forces uh the
reason that I think we'll be seeing that
is that uh interconnection is
increasingly the largest impediment to
deploying of any of these resources they
are they are low cost they make sense on
their own um but but finding a place to
plug them into the grid is getting
harder and harder and so uh I've heard
interconnection referred to as the pixie
dust of of these types of renewable
energy projects and so how do you
maximize the value of that very
expensive investment into
interconnection to the grid you do it
with storage by therefore maximizing how
much you know minimizing how much you
have to spend on the infrastructure
interconnect and maximizing how much
you're using that infrastructure so I
don't think we need a mandate I think
it'll happen on its
own follow up followup please um and
where what is the state of the uh
storage um ability how much energy can
you store how much does that cost so uh
the the cost of lithium ion storage is
falling rapidly there was a Quick bump
during the pandemic because of supply
chain issues um but you know the the uh
solution to high prices is high prices
and uh there have been massive
announcements of of uh lithium
processing capacity all around the world
and so the cost of lithium is fall or
lithium ion battery cells is is falling
again um it's it's around the
neighborhood of $150 per megawatt hour
presently um and and declining there are
also other sources of of storage that um
that have announced really impressive
figures in particular um there's a
company called form energy that has an
iron air battery that that claims to be
able to do $20 per megawatt hour um they
have just built a production facility in
West Virginia and are starting to deploy
their first projects um that are on a
pilot scale um and I'm very bullish on
that technology that's you know lithium
ion is typically in the neighborhood of
a 4our sort of a peaking resource you
you know you charge it during the the um
times of very low uh prices and then you
discharge typically in the evening and
on a daily cycle uh versus the iron air
battery is really it's almost a seasonal
storage uh uh technology where you can
charge it for you can discharge it for
weeks at a time can be a a you know
depending on the size of the battery you
put in you know one week two week 3 week
um resource so uh there's there's a lot
of innovation happening in the space and
I um I fully believe that by the time we
get to 2030 the the variability
challenge will be something that um that
feels much more soluble um I would say
though that currently we have a solution
to variability which is that we keep
capacity resources online and we just
run them less we use we use uh these
variable Renewables as fuel Savers and
that's exactly what was uh pointed out
by ISO New England and their decision to
close the Mystic station is that we are
saving enormous amounts of fuels and
that's what gets us through the cold
snaps and we're saving those fuels
because you know even in the winter The
Sun Shines and we don't have to burn
quite so much oil okay I think we're
getting a little bit off topic for the
bill and we do have to move on we have
five more speakers here so thank you Mr
Sim Evan Brown for your testimony and uh
thank you for setting the standard I'm
in the interest of time I'm going to
limit all other speakers to five minutes
or less if possible so next one on the
hopper is Mr Griffin Roberge of
doe
thank you Mr chairman uh for the record
Griffin robers State energy program
manager at the department of energy uh
all of you should have a letter of
testimony from the Department that I had
passed out earlier I think some of you
maybe weren't in the room when I passed
it out um as previously mentioned um the
department is neutral on this bill as
it's introduced um as has been discussed
the bill primarily amends the uh new
Hampshire State policy statement in RSA
378 colon 37 toward the bottom of page
two um it also empowers the department
or the Pu to open an investigation into
whether the forced retirement of an
electric generator from a Federal
Regulation affects the reliability or
affordability of the state's energy
resources um and then the department of
the Pu May recommend any action
necessary to defend the generator
including appealing to the New Hampshire
Department of Justice to file an action
in court or to participate in
administrative proceedings um I do want
to note that the department does
recognize that RSA 378 colon 37 is a
policy statement from the New Hampshire
general court but we do have some
observations on the modified statement
uh some of which has been mentioned in
previous testimony um on page one lines
29 to 30 to the first two lines on page
two um require or I should say state
that new hampsh shall promote the
development of resources to enhance the
state's ability to respond to
significant
disruptions um New Hampshire does as has
been previously mentioned function um in
a regional market um New Hampshire
certainly does take part in uh
advocating at the regional level for
State interest but we do want to note
that several of the responsibilities on
those lines uh are within the previe of
iso New England again New Hampshire
isn't a regional market we do not
operate on our own um second secondly um
page two
lines 5 to 7 as well as 8 to9
um might will will uh will conflict with
current state Energy Efficiency programs
and renewable energy program statutes um
so for example lines 8 to9 uh indicate
that energy conservation and Energy
Efficiency should be based on Market
principles without government subsidies
um this language does raise question
related to um rate payer Fund in Energy
Efficiency such as New Hampshire saves
especially uh considering the New
Hampshire General Court's action in
recent years with House Bill 549 and
Senate bill uh3 from last year um
additionally lines 5 to7 may be in
conflict with uh the state policy goal
under the renewable portfolio standard
to incentivize instate renewable uh
energy projects um the state's policy of
promoting renewable energy resources has
led to a regional market where uh
renewable energy certificates are sold
but that market would not exist without
government intervention so we did want
to note that um and then on the
paragraph a on page one which
is lines 24 to
26 and then on page two lines 16 to 17
uh conflict with one another in one of
these areas New Hampshire is promoting
the development of resources without
preference to technology type but with
an emphasis on dispatchable resources
while in the other New Hampshire is
promoting clean energy sources that may
not necessarily be dispatchable like
solar or wind so there is an
inconsistency there between those two
statements um regarding the tail end of
page two regarding um an investigation
into the Force retirement of electric
generators we do want to note that there
is no definition of electric generator
of what a Federal Regulation is or of
what a forced retirement is um given
that New Hampshire is part of a regional
grid could we be launching an
investigation into an electric generator
that's located in another state such as
Connecticut um you know does does the
bill only focus on instate generators or
out of state generators what constitutes
a Federal Regulation uh you know is it
an is it a federal rule is it an act of
Congress um again some of these things I
think think would be best uh kind of
ironed out with a little bit more
clarity if the department takes on this
uh responsibility and then finally um
the state investigation the bill does
indicate on
lines 23 I'm sorry 22 to 24 on page two
that the department or the Pu may open
an investigatory docket it may be an
inadequate use of resources if both the
department and the Pu had similar
investigations into the same thing um if
this bill is to move forward we would
suggest striking the pu's involvement in
this bill and just shift it over to the
department for an investigation um and
with that that will conclude my
testimony happy to take any
questions thank you for keeping it just
under five minutes
plus uh representative um
Kennedy thank you Mr Vice chair and
thank you for taking my question thank
you um you just mentioned that the state
of New Hampshire has promoted wind and
solar is that correct
uh yes under the state's renewable
portfolio standard follow-up question
sure followup uh do you have any idea
what the accumulated cost of that
promotion has been sure thank you for
the question so I don't have that number
off the top of my head but we do include
an annual reports on the renewable
energy fund happy to share that with the
committee
afterwards represent
chran thank you Mr Vice chair thank you
for taking my question um I was curious
to know your interpretation of um on
page two lines one through four I guess
um do you see compatibility or or
perhaps contrast between reserves of
proven and costeffective reserves versus
removing regulatory barriers to
Innovation um just those Innovation
versus proven um struck me as a little
bit incompatible and I'm not sure how
how would you consider proven um from
your Vantage Point sure I I so I I again
as I previously mentioned we at the
department view this statement as purely
a legislative statement within the
purview of the New Hampshire General
Court um in terms of maintaining
inadequate Supply including reserves of
proven and cost effective dispatchable
electricity reserves to meet grid demand
as I mentioned in my testimony you know
that responsibility is largely the
perview of iso New England um you know
to the extent the
state takes on these roles it it would
be a little bit of a shift from what
we've traditionally done
but again this is a a policy statement
so whatever the legislature deems
necessary to
include representative
keplan thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you Mr Rober for taking my question I
just wanted to follow up a little bit on
representative crean's question about
maintaining adequate supply of uh
reserves and you you you mention that
that would be a major shift and that
seems to be uh one of the aspirations of
this leg legislative uh of this bill is
to you know shift our policy and we can
argue about the aspirations and the
direction that it's going but it's clear
that it conflicts with some of the major
policy decisions that the state has
undertaken in the last 20 years but just
getting back to uh uh say we say that
state of New Hampshire was responsible
for maintaining adequate reserves how
would the state even do that sure sure
and thank you for the question I guess I
don't necessarily have an answer for
that again this doesn't this policy
statement is simply a policy statement
it doesn't impose any specific tasks or
responsibilities but it does indicate
the state of New Hampshire's or the
legislator's intent that the state will
be engaging in these things so if it
maybe becomes a policy that is r that is
adopted by the legislature and signed
into law it is something that you know
regulators and folks will be looking to
as you know means of undertaking
regulatory
action remind the U committee that we
have other speakers as well so I'm going
to ask I'm going to call on one last
question from representative Thomas
thank you Mr chair uh Vice chair um
thank you Mr robes for being here um you
testified that this bill um has flaws
that the bill has
inconsistencies that there's no
definitions there's elimination of State
programs and there's uh conflict with
ISO New England and there's an
inadequate use of resources and yet um
the department remains neutral
on this bill what would cause you to
oppose this bill sure and thank you for
the question again as I previously
stated this is a policy statement that
is adopted by the New Hampshire general
court and put into action by legislators
such as yourselves um we are respectful
of that this committee and other
legislators make that determination um I
I'm not going to hypothesize on what
would make us oppose the bill I can only
comment on the language that's in front
of me and as of right now we are
respectful of you know the dire
Direction the legislature wants to take
in modifying this and we've raised the
concerns and folks are certainly welcome
to consider that as they potentially
amend the
legislation thank you with that thank
you for your testimony Mr RAR thank you
and I'm going to call next on Miss Raley
Connors from New England power generator
uh please limit to approximately five
minutes
thank you for your time um for the
record my name is Molly Connors I'm with
the New England power generators
Association we're here to offer really
highlevel feedback on on
1623 um and for context um our policy is
really or our mission is to support
competitive wholesale s electricity
markets that are in New England that are
run and designed by ISO New England and
um regulated by um the federal
government um and for context throughout
New England our our Members Own and
operate about
27,300 megawatts of generating capacity
so it's fair to say that um we we our
Members Own and operate the vast
majority of the power plants um in the
in the region and within New Hampshire
our Members Own and operate about 4
4,300 megaw of generating capacity
employing about 1,500 people with
Millions paid in state and local taxes
um and I think it's important for us to
note that our members um own and operate
just about every type of generating um
technology there is they have fossil
fuel units but they also have renewable
units batteries solar wind Hydro nuclear
and um pumped Hydro storage so we offer
a wide range of um a wide perspective in
that regard regarding technology so I
first off I want to say that we really
appreciate that the committee is taking
time to recognize and discuss the
challenges that our generators our
members are facing in New England and we
want to highlight that they are facing
challenges Financial ones however the
types of challenges that our members are
facing are really
economics the vast majority of uh the
generating capacity in New England and
as was alluded to earlier the generators
that are not only providing energy and
capacity but frequency services and
other types of technical support they
recover their costs and E and really
live and die through the wholesale
electricity markets and those wholesale
electricity markets we have long
advocated are undervaluing the services
that our Market that our members provide
and so we have been working um in New
England with a variety of stakeholders
including ISO New England to improve the
wholesale electricity
markets and
I'm actually here to offer a little bit
of good news or something to be
optimistic about which is that is in New
England and the stakeholders um are are
working on improving the markets in a
way that are going to we think
meaningfully improve the the sort of
operating conditions and financial
conditions that our members are um
making living and dying by and so um we
want to say that anything that New
Hampshire wants to do in order to
address those Market challenges that our
members are facing ing are really best
done in collaboration with the other New
England states and this is because we
think that you know when you work across
state lines because our energy moves
across state lines the kinds of
improvements that you're going to get
are going to be more durable and more
long lasting and we also just would
would caution that the kinds of things
that states do outside the wholesale
electricity markets they can have
unintended adverse consequences and so
whenever we go to a state legislature
that's talking about doing things out of
Market um or outside the wholesale
electricity sort of Paradigm we we want
to caution and say you might have
unintended consequences that are um not
desirable and I also just in the
interest of time want to give a little
bit of context regarding the markets
that we're talking about the markets
that Isa New England runs and are
federally regulated that our members are
are operating
in they are designed to drive Innovation
flexibility and efficienc efficiency
while also removing risk from captured
rate payers and so um over time what the
wholesale electricity markets have done
is Drive prices lower we are actually in
a time of relatively low historic prices
at the wholesale level and that's
because the the Innovations and the
efficiencies that market participants
are doing are driving the cost to
generate electricity down overall that's
a good thing that's good for rate payers
certainly to have lower price at the
wholesale markets um it does create the
other challenge though that if you're an
older facility that maybe um has um
engineering challenges or um hasn't had
a lot of um Investments recently you're
less likely to be able to recover your
costs in the wholesale markets and
that's really the design of the market
and in turn the less efficient older
units get replaced and the by more
efficient faster more Nimble resources
in the last 10 years or so nearly 10
10,000 megaw of of efficient um Power
Generation has come online to replace
older less efficient resources and so
really the the takeaway is if there is a
resource if you have two resources to
choose from and one is older and less
efficient and one is newer and more
efficient the market is going to select
the newer one because it's going to be
more efficient and
Costless and so I just want to close by
um reiterating our gratitude that you
are looking at the challenge that our
our members are are facing want to
reiterate that we are working at the
regional level with stakeholders like
other generators ISO New England State
officials including State officials from
New Hampshire and officials from across
the region on fixing the wholesale
markets in a way that they can better
better uh remunerate our members for the
services that they provide and we
encourage New Hampshire to work um
collaboratively I know it can be more
challenging and more timec consuming but
it also leads to more durable um
improvements and um I'm happy to answer
any questions hopefully I hit the Tim
right thank you for
Testimony I'll take a few questions
representative
partial thank you chair and thank you
for your testimony today uh you uh
mentioned that Innovations were driving
down the market prices to Historic lows
and uh could you cite some examples of
those inovit in um Innovations as for my
edification um sure well I mean the
historic ly famous one that is now less
popular in many conversations is that
the cost the cost of building and
operating a natural gas plant um drove
the costs in the wholesale electricity
markets down that's because they were
more efficient than other existing
resources that were older and had more
expensive um fuels I know that many
would you know rather see an even
cleaner resource run but that's an
example of of an innovation that was not
driven by rirs that has driven the
prices of electricity at the wholesale
level down
honest answer sure representative
Berardi thank you Mr Vice chair so you
uh asked for collaboration amongst the
the states do do you think that
Massachusetts ban of pipelines is a
collaborative uh activity uh to
facilitate uh Power Generation in the
New England region uh are you referring
to the court order several years ago um
I'm referring to the the m Massachusetts
legislature Banning power uh Banning the
uh creation of new gas pipelines running
through the state as well as New York
has done the same
thing I um I have to admit I'm not
familiar with that particular law I do
know that there was a a decisive Supreme
Court decision that said that electric
rate pairs cannot subsidize natural gas
pipeline which is something within um
really about restructuring and who
should be bearing what risk what I can
say is that in New England the states
and really through the federal power act
the states have the really have the
responsibility the authority to decide
what resource mix is within their state
border and so if you know New Hampshire
you know has a disagreement with
Massachusetts that is the nature of you
know sort of State sovereignty which is
also at the heart of this law right or
the bill in front of us within our state
we should have a say and what the
resource mix
is and that's the reality my members
operate in every day okay we really need
to move on I'll take representative
mck's last question thank you Mr Vice
chair and thank you for taking my
question Miss Connor um so in terms of
this legislation that you came out here
to testify on um you mentioned in a very
delicate way unintended consequences uh
operating uh as though it's a regional
grid that we're participating in and so
I'm just wondering if if there is a
position uh in the power generators
Association
about whether uh passing this bill as it
currently appears would be useful or not
helpful to the overall circumstance you
you were talking about having outliers
with with uh rules that are very
different might might be difficult is
there anything difficult in this bill
that you can point to um well some I I
can give high level sort of General
feedback and and this came up in the
exchange with the Department of energy
um sort of you know to the to you never
want your power plants when they're
operating to have any confusion or um
conflicting signals about who's who they
should be following so in ISO New
England and I worked there for many
years um I'm partial to ISO New England
when they come up with their Market
rules they are designed to ensure
reliability and that it is in everyone's
best interest for the power plant to do
exactly what the control room says and
so one thing I would take away is if the
iso New England operators are saying
don't run we want to hold you in reserve
that that there's no ambiguity about
what a given power plan should be doing
because that's critical for reliability
um and the other thing I would just
remind everyone and we say this
everywhere um subsidies beget subsidies
when you try to prevent a a power plant
from retiring one of the things that is
an option is to take that power plant
out of the markets and just put it on a
special contract and that contract is
going to be more expensive than what the
wholesale price was and and it's going
to make the problems within the
wholesale Market where prices are
already low even more difficult for the
existing members that aren't seeking to
retire so there that's the kind of
unintended consequence I would allude to
thank you that's very helpful yeah well
thank you so much for your testimony I
appreciate it we we do have time
constraints and I'll move on to Mr Nick
coff of the conservation law foundation
for his five minutes or less
testimony
hey good morning uh my name is Nick
croff for the conservation law
Foundation um thank you for having me
testify
today currently under the under the
language in
378-3739 policy to favor fossil fuel
fossil fuels above all other concerns um
it perversely assumes that fossil fuels
are good for the environment for the
public health and the safety of the
state while completely ignoring their
environmental impacts and their Public
Health impacts um as we've heard several
times New Hampshire is part of iso New
England and I don't agree with a lot
with what ISO New England does but I
think they do a reasonably good job of
keeping the lights on for our region so
this bill's concern about reliability
dispatchability Etc is really misplaced
given iso's function um you know what's
a far far greater concern is um you know
that What's happen you know the the
effects of fossil fuel use and the
continued effects of fossil fuel use um
you know as as we're all aware um fossil
fuel use is is negatively damaging our
climate and is um you know causing
negative Health impacts with all the
particular matter from from many power
plants causing asthma health um heart
disease other other um netive Health
impacts and so you know but this bill
completely ignores ignores those impacts
by you know placing the thumb on the
scale in favor of fossil fuels um you
know and with that in
mind um the bill claims to be
technologically neutral but you know
again as we've heard it contradicts
Itself by requiring a um an analysis of
the um you know of the life cycle
emissions for clean energy Technologies
but not a similar analysis for fossil
fuels so you know it's not it's not
technologically neutral even though it
claims to be um and then
third fossil fuel plants aren't as
dispatchable or as reliable as we've
been led to believe um a recent report
by synaps uh energy economics found that
it takes 12 hours for Marx station to
turn on so that's not really a
dispatchable resource and then we we saw
in late 2022 the Christmas Eve storm
winter um winter storm Elliot you know
many oil plants natural gas plants
failed to turn on when there was a um
you know a system issue that day and so
you know there's there's reliability
issues with with natural gas and and oil
plants coal plants that are just being
glossed over by this um conversely
storage combined with Renewables have a
you know have more and more potential to
provide dispatchability and reliability
services to the grid um there's there's
a new storage project in gorm main being
built um that would provide a lot of
liability benefits the grid um and then
finally last point I want to make is
that with respect to this investigation
that doe and pu could conduct into um
Force retirements I think I understand
it a little bit better after
Representatives Bose as explanation
but a lot of a lot of these potential
regulations that would be investigated
you know that the remedy that that might
be um effectuated by Doe or or the Pu
are going to be preempted by federal law
and so you know I I think I understand
the the purpose there but you know there
there's an awful lot of federal
regulations that the state's not be able
to do anything about and so it seems to
be a waste of time and uh and resources
to require um doe to go through this
futile exercise um but thank you very
much happy to answer any
questions thank you so much for your
testimony uh representative
kman thank thank you Mr Vice chair and
thank you Mr cof for taking my question
I'm going to ask you a question that I
would have liked to have asked this
bill's sponsor and then U Mr Evans brown
but I wasn't called on but I'm going to
ask you for your opinion on this and
that is is it even possible to talk
about ignoring Market forces and I
understand that you know we've already
discussed um NH saves as um possibly
putting its thumb on Market forces but
it seems that uh there are other Market
forces outside of New Hampshire that
influen things such as uh federal tax
credits for Renewables such as the oil
depletion allowance is it even possible
to say everything is going to be only
Market forces I mean no and I I think
you know that that kind of you
know um you know with utility regulation
you know it's the antithesis of the
market you know it's a heavily it's a
heavy regulated um you know industry
that basically gives utilities a
monopoly over over providing gas and
electric service and so you know there's
not a market there and yeah I I don't
think you can really
divorce um you know what's happening in
New Hampshire from what's happening at
the federal level with with incentives
you know e either you know either
incentives for clean energy technology
or you know the continued failure to um
completely completely account for the
externalities of of fossil fuel
use okay seeing no other questions thank
thank you so much for your testimony
appreciate it I'm going to call next on
miss m friedricks from Durham
representing 350 New Hampshire uh again
time five minutes or less
please thank you um everyone for
welcoming me to the to the podium this
morning um and for hearing me and again
uh for the record my name is m
friedricks and I'm representing 350 NH
um so I wanted to start by um kind of
echoing our support for representative
vos's statement um when he introduced
this bill that the grid is essential the
electric grid is essential to human
health and stability is in ut utmost
importance um in those considerations um
but we do have several concerns um where
this uh bill as introduced is
self-contradictory and some questions
that we would like to um voice for the
committee as well um so the first one um
is lines uh eight and n on page two um
where it states that New Hampshire shall
shall pursue energy conservation and
efficiency according to Market
principles um and as mentioned by some
other um folks today who gave T their
testimony um there that in in practice
um conflicts with language elsewhere
about pursuing affordability cost
Effectiveness and low consumer prices
because we have seen that there are a
number of benefits um when subsidies are
used appropriately um such as through
the New Hampshire saves
program um another area of concern um is
uh again page two lines 16 and 17 um as
brought up um earlier in testimony today
that um you know this this uh Bill
states that New Hampshire shall promote
the use of clean energy sources by
considering the emissions of an energy
resource throughout the entire life
cycle um and yet uh on um in line 25 on
page one um we state that there is
without preference for technology type
and so we do agree with representative
's statement earlier in this hearing um
that really the entire life cycle should
be considered for all energy types and
not for only clean energy um I also
wanted to um add that there's concern
that um this bill would add a Le a level
of government intervention um in
addition uh sorry that is not limited
narrow or necessary because we do
already have have um the Pu um acting in
on behalf of New Hampshire in
coordination with regional authorities
um I also have the the experience of
having lived in Argentina for um almost
10 years of my adult life which I think
has become famous for its economic
crisis and in that experience I really
learned firsthand that when regulation
and
administration becomes political that
that is the most destabilizing Force um
in ex distance and really um when we
make our our um our Administration and
um our regulation of of things like our
utilities uh a political Choice then
that is destabilizing um to the economy
and um to our society um we have some
questions about who would pay um to keep
a generator running if they were noticed
um because given that uh right now we
operate in uh a regional grid
um and the payment comes through the
regional grid if um a facility was
instructed to shut down um through some
regulatory body at the regional or
federal level um what would happen in
terms of the payment to keep that
facility running would it be New
Hampshire taxpayers then that are
continuing to operate that facility um
entire on tax entirely on taxpayer money
um while a decision is made about
whether or not that facility should um
should be shut down
and then um lastly we share some uh
concerns about the use of the word
dispatchable throughout this text um
because it's really unclear if you have
one site that is a battery storage
facility and that is operated by a
separate owner from something that is a
renewable facility um and yet those two
can operate in conjunction to provide
dispatchable energy how is that being
considered um and that's really unclear
in the language that is provided here um
and then lastly we also um Echo concerns
um previously stated uh about replacing
the the language from 378 uh colon 37
because that definition was um reviewed
last year and decided that it was really
the best possible language so reopening
that and revisiting that this year does
not seem a prudent um course of action
thank
you thank you for your
testimony representative Kenny
Kennedy uh thank you Mr Vice chair and
thank you for taking my question um you
mentioned the impact of political forces
would you say there are political forces
here behind the promotion of wind and
solar um I think when when I made that
statement what I was really looking at
is um I think we want to be very careful
about sending conflicting messages to um
businesses who operate as public
utilities and to all of the businesses
and people who rely on the electric grid
um if we have um sort of fighting
occurring between um the the New
Hampshire state government and the other
regulatory bodies that oversee our
regional grid so that's really the
political instability that um that I was
speaking to here follow
up yeah I may have misinterpreted what
you were meaning by political
instability but could you still answer
the question um I don't feel like I have
any information to answer that question
so my answer would be no but um I I
don't feel well enough informed to to
explain why that would be no it would be
based on I I don't have any information
on
that representative
partiel thank you chair and thank you
for your testimony um you were speaking
of Market forces and sometimes my
feeling is that market forces would tell
me the best way to heat my house is to
burn it down without really thinking
about what I'm going to be doing
tomorrow um and this leads to my
question do you feel that there's an
appropriate role for our legislature to
protect the interest of the public both
environmentally and E economically by
riging in some Market forces when they
become
excessive um I absolutely do think that
the legislature plays an important role
in protecting the Health and Welfare of
New Hampshire residents and I think that
that role is um you know happens through
the the the bills um that are put forth
and are decided on by our legislature so
I think um you know as stated in others
testimony and I do not pretend to be an
expert by any means on um you know on
the the electric grid and that's why I
kind of stated that um we we wanted to
share some comments and some questions
that we had uh because I think some
other folks have have much greater
expertise when they shared their
testimony but um I I can um you know uh
agree that
the public utilities is an unusual space
and that because it does not operate
entirely on Market forces um it is a
legal Monopoly which would not be a
Market Force um there are tighter
regulations that are that are imposed in
order to counterbalance that so um
that's the the best that I can um
respond to that question that's adate
thank you so much seeing that other
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you for coming down here again I'm
going to call on the next speaker and I
I'll make this comment we've had a lot
of test Tony here today on this bill and
uh we're beginning uh we we're hearing
the same testimonies uh involving their
same concerns on same portions of of the
bill so on uh your rest of the
testifiers if you could just merely
agree with some of the concerns that
have been previously stated and if we
have any new information to to talk
about we would certainly be glad to hear
that with that being said I'm going to
ask on Miss Heidi croll to come up here
from Grand estate uh Hy Hydro Power
Association welcome thank you Mr
chairman uh good morning everyone for
the record my name is Heidi croll I work
at Gallagher cahan and gartell and I'm
representing the granite state hydr
Power Association here today before you
I will be brief um we do um share some
of the concerns that have been raised by
other speakers here before me today um
we appreciate the um focus on uh
resilience and reliability um and in
part we think that comes from um
diversity of resources and we just
wanted to note that um the word
diversity has actually been removed it's
in it's in current law but we don't see
the word diversity in the bill um but uh
the word dispatchable appears seven
times and from a um Hydro run of river
perspective we just wanted to share that
you know technically we are not
dispatchable um in the sense that other
you know kind of the traditional sense
um but run of river is very reliable it
has some seasonal variability um but
generally uh it's running 247 unless
there's some sort of mechanical problem
with the facility so um you know we just
wanted to um say that we would have some
concerns with the with the emphasis on
dispatchability um and also had the same
flag that Doe brought up about um uh
this legislation versus the RPS law RPS
law with that um happy to answer any
questions and I will we briefy New Year
on a time schedule thank you very much
I'll call on representative U Thomas's
time thank you Mr chair um I understand
you have some concerns um can you
clarify do oppose or uh support this
bill uh we are opposed as
introduced thank you representative
Kennedy thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question um you mentioned that
diversity leads to increased
reliability but would you say that
adding an unreliable resource to the mix
increases
reliability well I think we come at it
from the perspective of um you know it's
kind of like your finances uh when
you're going with a portfolio um you
know different different resources have
different strengths and different
weaknesses um and depending on what's
happening in the markets happening with
weather um a whole variety of factors um
the diversity I think does overall um
bring some strength and and resilience
to the
grid thank you seeing none others thank
you for your testimony appreciate it and
uh we will call on the last testifier Mr
John Gage representing himself and again
please limit to 5 minutes or less with
any new testimony that you may have
thank
you
thank you Mr Vice chairman thank you
committee
um I'm John Gage from Windham
represented myself uh I agree with all
of the opposition uh testimony that has
come before me
um I guess uh starting with the um the
idea of this as being an energy
Independence bill um it seems like this
is the opposite to me uh it ties us
further to the fossil fuel industry um
if we were striving for energy
Independence in a state we would be
heavily investing in Energy
Efficiency um wind and solar and Battery
uh and a smarter grid that would let
micro grids and
um and local Generation Um proliferate
uh diversity of energy sources is
hurting us right now we we are heavily
reliant on gas for our electricity
because of the regional production and
we felt that a couple years ago when our
prices spiked due to the volatility of
the gas market
globally
um I was a software developer for 35
years and uh yes elegant code is what
software developers strive for in my
group we used to say we need clean crisp
code and it's interesting looking at
legislature because it's very much like
software software you have a grammar and
you write rules and then things execute
through it and work gets done in
legislature is the same way you write
rules and things
happen um we had a term for code that
was not well written and simple uh
spaghetti code um so there may be some
legislature that you could consider
spaghetti code also um with hidden
motives and trying to tip the the scale
in certain ways that causes problems in
markets there's a lot of discussion
about Market forces and market pricing
in this
language but nothing about the market
failure um the largest market failure in
the history of human civilization
according to Sir Nicholas Stern in the
stern report the external costs of using
fossil
fuels um these are not reflected in the
price of fossil fuels and this is a
market failure a classic market failure
from pollution and we're struggling
under that market failure right now
there's a lot of legislation trying to
deal with it in different
ways but there's a heavy influence of
the fossil fuel industry
um the Koch Network front
groups trying to continue their social
engineering which has been going on for
decades to avoid us dealing with their
pollution from accepting it to
regulating it and now we're even
ignoring what's going on in the rest of
the world uh in the United States and
specifically New Hampshire the handout
that I just provided to you has a couple
graphs from the state and trends of
carbon pricing report from the world
Bank this body may not like talking
about carbon pricing very much uh it's a
tax on energy right that's what the
fossil fuel industry wants to call it
economists say we're internalizing the
external costs of the pollution from
fossil fuels and their price so that we
get efficient market forces providing
the best benefits to
all carbon pricing is spreading around
the world it's in 23% of all fossil fuel
sold right now 73 73 countries and
regions are pricing carbon and that's
triple what it was a decade ago and
prices are rising and Border carbon
adjustments are starting in Taiwan and
soon in the EU countries are going to
start charging us exporters their carbon
price when we export goods into their
Market the EU has a price of $85 per ton
kind of the the low watermark for a safe
future is $135 per ton of CO2 emitted in
2030 Canada is using cash back carbon
pricing to hit that Target and the EU is
rising rapidly will obviously be closer
above that also and these countries are
going to start charging the US exporters
their carbon price this is
spreading I I want our state not to keep
its head in the sand about this we
should anticipate a federal carbon price
sometime this day
decade so back to
Simplicity carbon pricing is the
simplest way to to deal with pollution
because if you charge the fossil fuel
industry a polluter fee the cost of
pollution is reflected in the price of
everything this
incentivizes clean energy and Energy
Efficiency um and it's going to happen
to us and New Hampshire is not going to
have a say about whether it happens but
we can anticipate it
so Market forces are great but when
there's incorrect pricing in a market
you make bad decisions if you just base
your decisions on current
prices so I would rewrite this whole
bill and
say let's leave RSA
378.5 s alone it sounds like an elegant
explanation of what our uh energy agenda
is um what we should do for State energy
policy is simply anticipate a minimum
federal carbon price coming at us the
document that I gave you gave the price
Model that we a very conservative one
that's happening around the world um by
anticipating this we would invest in
Energy Efficiency we would stop trying
to prop up fossil fuel energy we would
start accelerating our efforts to figure
out how to modernize our grid to prepare
for things like what Mr Sam Evans Brown
so eloquently spoke about in an energy
conference last year virtual power
producers batteries spread out which can
work together with software and provide
dispatchable energy cheaply so thank you
for hearing my testimony I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you m Gage
you
uh exceeded 5 minutes just a little bit
but you're able to sum up something
about the bill in a few seconds so so
thank you um seeing no other questions
thank you so much for your testimony
having no other pink cards I declare the
uh public hearing for 1623 closed
Point did I a quick question if I
could and the bell we um one of my
constituents has asked if we could read
the online uh the uh results of the
online submissions and how many people
signed it on the blue sheet
and I'm wonder if we're still doing
that I don't believe we're not reading
the online submissions but we can report
the results of blue sheet if if we have
it do we have
it I'm sorry Vice chair um today I don't
have my electronic device and our
assistant is not available I could give
you the blue sheet or the online
submissions if you would like I I will
get the blue sheet thank you
okay there'll be a short intermission
before we so we can change
chairs
okay let's open a public hearing on
House Bill 1487 relative to the health
health effects of 5G technology and I'll
ask representative geard the prime
sponsor to introduce this
legislation representative Gart
morning
committee Jason Gard norfield Franklin
marac
1487 seeks to Institute recommendations
from the 2020
5G commission
report
there are there's a number of
recommendations and I did not want to
print out a ton of paper so I sent a
link in your email to the 5G commission
report if you want to follow along it's
Pages 9 through 9 through 17 are
basically what we'll be working
from so starting from the
beginning this let's let's start from
beginning
beginning I don't want to claim that I'm
an expert on the effects
of not just 5G but the Wi-Fi and
cellular radiation in
general what this seeks to do is simply
alert the public to
the the amount of radiation that they're
receiving and allowing them to make the
decision if they wish
to well basically take it in and if not
then at least they'll know how to avoid
it and where it's being at the highest
levels so
the on line 10 we start with the
Department of Environmental Services
shall include links on the department
website that conclud uh contains
information about radio frequency
radiation from all sources including 5G
small cells deployed on public rights
away such information shall Al also
contain guidance on the proper use of
cell phones to minimize exposure to RF
radiation simple there's simple things
we can do as well simply putting phones
on airplane mode when putting them
against your body in your pocket things
to minimize radiation exposure that
don't really require much effort but it
does take knowledge and I didn't know
about that simple trick until
researching this so we also have public
service announcements on radio
television media to warn women
newborns and well really pregnant women
is what I meant to say about the
potential
harms and this is something I'm
particularly uh excited about is line 17
number three the Department of
Environmental Services shall develop
exposure warning signs for posting in
commercial and public buildings
concerning RF radiation levels just to
allow people to know what they're being
exposed
to that's from recommendation recom uh
recommendation 13 recommendation three
which is on line 19 the Department of
invironmental Services shall require
that every poll or other structure in
the public rights away holding a 5G
antenna to be labeled in indicating RF
radiation being emitted from the antenna
such label shall be posted at eye level
and printed in such a way that is
legible from 9 ft
away I I just don't I know we're way
behind schedule I don't want to go
through everything I'm trying
to cover the ones that I think
are very simple to implement and very
important the line let's go to page two
line six home inspectors shall be
trained to measure the intensity of RF
radiation when doing inspections home
inspectors shall send measurements of RF
radiation to the Department of
Environmental Services for publication
on a map of state exposure levels that
way people will now be able to see where
radiation exposure is the most and I
think that when people are buying homes
that is something that they should know
about if they know about mold and other
possibly harmful elements to their
health then I think radiation exposure
is something something that should be
known as
well then I know the from the previous
terms HB 1644 dealing with setbacks for
wireless Towers this line 11 15 this is
a 1500t setback for new wireless
antenna and we
have on line 15 this is from
recommendation 14 recommendation 4 I'm
sorry the board shall develop a plan to
be implemented in every school district
to migrate from wireless internet
connections for computers laptops
tablets and other wireless devices to
internet connections that are either
hardwired or Optical connections within
5 years so obviously we can't transition
everything immediately but to to Simply
start moving away from Wi-Fi systems to
hardwired or Optical and
hopefully get away from the
Wi-Fi systems that are not beneficial to
human life and
Wildlife um and that also is for
chartered schools as
well and that's that's basically the
bill I mean there's more to it there's a
couple
more for on page one real quick let's go
over and we have time 23 P line
23 doing signal measurements around
Wireless facilities in order to evaluate
signal characteristics
and the rules take into account the
impulsive nature of high data rate
radiation that's different than simply
steady
rate and that's exact that's basically
it I'll take questions but I I don't
want to Caan to be an expert on this I
simply came across the 5G commission
report I know a lot of people there's
several people here that came to testify
in support of this and we're concerned
about the health effects and don't feel
that ignoring the the potential human
effects is something we can continue to
do
anymore thank you uh representative
Kaplan had a question for you yeah thank
you uh Mr chair and thank you
representative Gart for coming in I just
have a quick question did you base this
legislation on any other templates from
other states or do you know of any other
states that are carrying out similar
legislation
no this is from the 5G commission report
that was you know commissioned by the
governor and it's simply taking the
there's a 300 page report and I don't
understand why we went through all the
effort of having a commission all those
hours of study just to walk away from it
and that's I just I think this deserves
a hearing by a competent body and I'm
not claiming to be the competent expert
but I feel that the people on the
commission were and this deserves a
hearing
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative geart it's nice to see
you again um when you asked us to go
take a look at the report because you
sent the link I I did as you instructed
and I noticed that when you sent us to
page 19 it's a section of the report
that's uh titled Minority Report so the
recommendations before that were
from no what are you oh I I I said not
page nine but I'm sorry
oh you said page nine page nine is
recommendation is that where the
recommendation start okay okay um all
right I might have misspoke I'm
having because I went right there okay I
was just GNA say it looks like there was
a sort of a subcommittee that did
separate work um and there are
um there are footnotes on the page that
say the commission discussions indicated
the commission was comprised of many
individuals had who had preconceived
opinions about the safety of RF devices
and wireless technology in general and
due to many factors experts in favor of
Wireless technology were cut short from
participating um while other experts uh
who were opposing RF devices were
allowed to to testify so it just goes on
to kind of say that it wasn't
necessarily A an evenly balanced effort
I don't know if were you involved in the
effort or are you just referring to the
report that came out of that sub
committee I'm referring to the report
that came out of the full body the full
but you weren't you weren't on it right
no this is back in 2020 okay thank
you representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair um re I'm just
looking at the practicality of of this
um of this proposed Bill sure on lines
um page two lines 4 through five and
it's just this whole the home inspector
and I assume when you mean home home
inspector you also mean building analyst
but it talks about how they're going to
be required to report RF
radiation so an uh an EMF detector costs
about $500 so um the co who pays for the
cost of that who does the training that
that you reference in the bill and who
validates the results that are coming
in
so this is from recommendation eight
it's it's page two it's sort of like it
starts at like line four no no I
understand I was trying to preface what
I was going to say so this is from
recommendation 8 and this is the full
recommendation from the report was
upgrade the educational offerings by the
New Hampshire office of professional
license certification for home
inspectors to include RF intensity
measurements home inspectors currently
operate as private contractors who may
be hired by citizens or Enterprises to
measure such things as radon to collect
water samples or search for mold or
insect damage home inspectors routinely
Supply test results to both their
clients and government entities the
majority of the commission believes the
public has a right to discover on a
voluntary basis the RF power intensity
related to radio frequencies at a
property which they will be purchasing
or renting before the transaction is
closed also the Proprietors of publicly
accessible venues may wish to reassure
the public about the RF power intensity
within their establishments by posting
the data collected by a state approved
inspector in addition such testing sh
should be paid for by the party
requesting it and the testing itself
should be performed by a professional
who owns or rents the test equipment and
has met the state requirements for
training of home inspectors regarding RF
measurements the majority of the
commission proposes that home inspectors
be offered training by NH oplc on how to
measure the on-site Peak and 24-hour
average RF intensities measurements of
frequencies and intensities will be
performed using lowcost equipment such
as GQ 390
MERS okay
followup yes follow up all right on my
second uh concern about practicality is
in lines 15 through 18 where you say the
board shall develop a plan to implement
in every school district I assume that
means public school yeah um to mitigate
from wireless internet connection for
computers laptops tablets and other
wireless devices to inter internet
connections that are hardwired or
Optical connections is there a carve out
or would this impact specialed students
who need wireless devices for
communication I'm well I mean I first
the easiest answer would be that you
guys at the committee you guys can
change the bill as you see fit but I
didn't know there was a need for that I
never that didn't occur to me so I'll
have to admit that much if you want I
can read the recommendation from the
actual report if no that's fine that's
fine thank you pretty
sure representative Kennedy has a
question thank you thank you Mr chairman
and thanks for taking my question um you
know the the gist of the bill as far as
I see it is that you would like the
state to intervene to you know reduce or
even eliminate wireless
communication and I think that's a
pretty tall order but um do you think
that's Justified for the state to do
that given the the percentage of the
public that has this
concern I think that's a
mischaracterization
I think the public should
know the radio
frequency levels that they're being
exposed
to okay um representative Ley has a
question uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative I noticed that there
are a number of things here that would
be mandated um and they will cost money
and why is there no fiscal
note I can't answer that question
okay thank you all right seeing no
further questions thank uh
representative Gerard for U introducing
this bill and call next on Mark retti of
kukk welcome to
sdn Good morning thank you um I'm just a
regular old guy from the street not a
scientist not into Technologies very
largely but um there is a cell tower
that is approximately 90 ft from the
corner of my
home and I've been renting there for 12
years now next week it'll be 12 years um
homes in the neighborhood people have
moved in and purchase those
homes and I've become friendly with my
neighbors have always been
they end up moving out now the tower
stands let's say it's
here I'm very close to it but all of
these people are within 1,500 1200
ft um one of the
children that lived in one of these
homes uh was fantastic and she came down
with brain cancer and her vision was
going away at 6 years old and they
packed up and moved out U another
Resident moved into a different house
that house has been moved out of three
times and they said there's something
wrong here there's something wrong with
the energy well my cousin worked in the
military developing weapons and he told
me about the dangers of
electromagnetic um energy and radiant
energy and he sent me this little
meter I walk outside with this and hold
it up like this and it starts
screaming you hold it next to your phone
it does a little bit of light beeping
you hold it next to a microwave that's
running it goes off like that
Tower this little machine has prove to
me how
unsafe this energy is that comes off of
these towers forget the money that the
towers make and the ne necessity for
communications and this and that these
are very dangerous to people 5G operates
at a wavelength that is used by the
military for damaging or burning the
skin of other human beings and they use
it they point of that people for crowd
control and they can move the people
around um so that's basically what I
wanted to say um also with this little
tool came this
guide and it spells out here and I only
very quickly
read um all the things that have
happened to these neighbors they've got
listed here for this machine being one
of the causes of leukemia for children
can cause cancer and accelerate
proliferation of cancer cells cause
direct harm to the human General system
male and female nervous system and
immune system can cause mental
disabilities of children dimin of vision
affect tissue development and skeletal
development of children this is a pretty
mean
stuff um can cause uh liver problems and
one of the main causes of card uh card
vascular disease and
diabetes um so if anybody here has a lap
top I would just like to hold this in
front of the laptop and let you see the
power that comes out of
them
yes thank you maybe you could do that
offline uh out in the hallway I don't
think it's appropriate for right here in
the
committee Mr retti would you please uh
take your seat thank you thank you
appreciate you coming to talk to us
today next up is Andrew Thatcher of
CTI
morning I'm Andrew Thatcher I'm a board
certified health physicist and I'm here
to talk in strong opposition to the
proposed Bill I'm just going to go at a
high level there because we've only got
a couple minutes get to
okay can you hear me
okay so the proposed bill is worried
about fifth gener eration technology but
5G includes 600 MHz 2500 MHz 5.5 GHz the
600 mahz used to be part of the UHF TV
Spectrum until
2018 the 2.4 2.5 GHz 5.5 GHz that's part
of the Wi-Fi networks we have in just
about every home and just about every
office building so I think the concern
probably is related to millimeter wave
the higher newer frequencies that are
used in 5G and so just at a high level
let's just talk about those exposures
briefly so millimeter waves which could
be 24 28 gigahertz 37 39 GHz
currently that's about 100,000 times
less energetic than the minimum energy
necessary which is ultra violet light to
cause any kind of genetic damage other
than tissue heating which is the basis
of our standards which were
recently updated late 2019 same uh with
the worldwide itner regulations those
were
2020 so these 5G antennas for the
millimeter wave antennas they're beam
forming antennas so they only have an
antenna directed at a user and nobody
else and because they're using those
antennas just to an individual person
the output power from the individual
antennas is about a tenth of a watt so
even if I were standing in front of an
antenna array and let's say we've got 64
antennas in there I'm a few feet away
that total exposure is no more than a
handheld walkie Taki I use when I go
hiking so you were talking about five
six Watts total so combined with all
other exposures the 5G millimeter waves
is a negligible contribution to exposure
there's just not a lot there
um as far as the bill goes I could go
into a lot of details I obviously don't
have time for that there are expert
reviews that are done every single year
sponsored by health organizations or
governmental those are all available
I've in my written testimony gave a few
examples of citations for those uh the
instruments that are used for those and
I do own one those are over $10,000 for
the instruments to do accurate
measurements for this it cost a couple
thousand for calibration these are not
cheap instruments home inspectors are
not able to generally operate things
like this they simply cost a whole lot
of money um I'll open it up to questions
and I thank you for your time thank you
for coming here today and giving us your
written and spoken testimony appreciate
that questions from the committee
representative
Harrington thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question um
maybe you can help out a little bit here
because you know we've been dealing with
this issue now for a number of years it
was a study bill before this and we
continue to get two dynamically opposed
positions one is from people like
yourself that say that there is no
Health effect and that uh guidelines are
in effect and so forth and so on and
it's not an issue and then with the
other people that say it's totally
ruining their lives so uh I understand
you have a very impressive background in
health physics but why do these people
people think it's ruining their lives if
there is no Health threat that that's a
great question I mean I've been working
in this field for 30 almost 35 years I'm
an expert Adent for the state of Hawaii
dealing with 5G right now actually so
that's in my experience it's been
knowledge that actually reduces the the
concerns a lot of times I'll give talks
for two or three hours and and walk
through the exposures walk through the
fact that uh these are just radio waves
they're the same thing that we've been
using since the 20s or 30s so the fact
that it's digitized or or it's
continuous or analog doesn't really
change the fact that it's just pure
energy and and what really matters is
the amount of energy being deposited the
basis of the standards is solely based
on heat and it's not because we haven't
been trying to find other causes or
other impacts uh from the exposures it's
simply the fact that there's just pure
energy and the basis as far as the cells
concern we do a lot of androgenous
exogenous heat is generated in our
cellular level all the time you have to
overcome a given amount of that for it
to even be meaningful but the standards
are very protective for all ages there
was a recent um report or summary uh for
pregnant women which was mentioned and
that was just published in October
2023 and it reaffirms that the only
adverse effects are at levels that are
like 60 to 250 times what the allowable
public limit is so followup followup and
just to be clear we're dealing here with
100% nonionizing radiation correct I you
know they use radiation I'm a nucle
engineer by training uh from the Navy so
uh I I'm I'm used to the term radi
because I do in medical world in
ionizing radiation this isn't really
radiation it's simply a radio wave and
and honestly it's it's not heartful I
know that the millimeter waves are new
but back in the 70s can microwave ovens
were new and there was huge concerns
about we're putting cancer boxes in our
kitchens and I don't think anyone
believes that anymore it's simply a new
technology a new application but it's
still a radio wave at its basic level
representative liwicki has a question um
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um can you give us
some idea of what the depth of
penetration is of various things at
various frequencies and Powers uh for
instance at a 100 um you know uh you
know low frequency AM radio penetration
to uh 23 GHz thanks for letting me do
that because I forgot to mention that so
let's go to higher the millimeter waves
uh at 24 or 39 gigahertz they penetrate
a millimeter into the body so they don't
go beyond the depth of the skin that's
it so your only exposure potential is to
your eyes or to the skin now as you get
lower in frequencies as far as the human
body is concerned resonant frequency is
about 70 megahertz which is basically
close to FM radio that would be that
would be a radio signal that's a long
enough wavelink that is absorbed very
efficiently into the body so usually the
frequencies like a Wi-Fi network that's
about a centimeter into the body not
very far so even then you're not getting
into Target organs or something of
concern to the body does that help
thanks okay seeing no further questions
I want to thank you for being here and
offering your testimony and call the
last person who wants to speak on this
issue and that's ranne Chester of
Bedford
welcome to
SD thank you committee chair thank you
committee members um I was here uh prior
to the committee being established in
2020 so I may be able to answer some of
the questions that folks have you won't
see a lot of people coming to testify
about this right now because they have
saved their families and that's why
they're not here they have decided that
it's more important to just get away
from what they believe is harming their
their families and their children um I
would encourage all of you folks to
listen to the heartwrenching testimony
that was that created that
commission it was
heart-wrenching um I've heard a lot back
then and I heard some today it's cost-
prohibitive it's um they want easier
faster access but at what cost that's
the one thing that all these PE
proponents that are pro um increasing
radio waves and uh radio frequencies
that's what they fail to tell us they
say this will give you quick easy
access at the cost of potentially your
health they never mention that and
that's not okay we have spent a lot of
time time on this commission and there
were a number of good things that came
out of that commission and nothing was
done with it and we spent a lot of money
on that commission too by the way um
because we did a lot of
researches
um in the 60s it was the anti nausea
medicine it was safe and effective
everyone believed it look at what we did
to our children DDT
Roundup aluminum and talcum powder the
pfas from St Kain took almost n years to
prove that they had been DET destroying
people what if we're right what if all
these crazy conspiracist conspiracy
theorists about they know their family
they know when they moved into these
facil these areas that they started
having problems that's what they know
what if they're right is the state of
New Hampshire willing to say you're not
going to be able to say we didn't know
you the state of New Hampshire will be
liable for all the damage that is being
done to our
citizens if we move forward um they
talked a little bit about the commission
report and I just want to speak to the
comments on uh it was not equally
balanced if you look at that report um
it was very very equally balanced um the
problem is is that everybody in that
report other than the people on that
commission that were benefiting from the
technology was against the technology
that doesn't mean it's not balanced that
means that there are a lot more people
that said there's a lot of
problems
uh I look
at right now what's going on in our
country there's a lack of trust there's
a lack of trust for the science there's
a lack of trust for our government
there's a lack of a trust for our
scientists because everybody has a price
and when I hear when I've read some of
these um settlement
agreements the Johnson and Johnson
settlement agreement they
knew the risk of putting aluminum into
our bodies they took it anyways because
it it was a cost risk
benefit that should not be
okay that should not be okay I've heard
people speak to hear about um the
practicality shouldn't the practicality
of Life be more important than the cost
benefit
analysis shouldn't it be more important
and more importantly this bill is not
eliminating 5G it is not a li it is not
trying to destroy all our technology it
is merely a bill to say let's start
being proactive for a change the state
of New Hampshire needs to be proactive
instead of just jumping on the bandwagon
and saying okay now we have another
hundred million lawsuit settlement that
we have to try and pay let's be
proactive and let's start reporting a
$500 um EMF or
RF recorder is not prohibitive to a
building inspector it is not building
inspectors make a lot of money off of
their profession and actually it's a
huge and increasing need if anything it
would benefit our our communities
because we would be able to encourage
more building inspectors to come to go
into that profession because they truly
feel like they're doing something we are
already do it with black mold we all
already do it with so many
things I was personally affected by St
Copan and PF the PFS p psfs p whatever
um the bottom line is is that we started
screaming almost nine years before the
final settlement says oh yeah we were
doing that they they St Cobain had done
it everywhere where they'd been and
still it was allowed to happen to our
communities that's not
okay so I want all of you to really
consider as you're thinking about this
bill the importance of what's what's
more important the lives of our New
Hampshire citizens or the pockets of our
people who are benefiting from this kind
of
resource thank you and I'm willing to
take any questions well thank you we
appreciate you coming down to give us
your perspective questions
for I see none so thank you very much
and we have no further pink cards no
people who want to testify on this
uh I haven't seen any further pink cards
are there pink cards out there that I
should
see didn't get to
you
so apparently we do have another person
who would like to speak to us Alexandra
Manelli from we New Hampshire and
um please uh keep your remarks brief and
try not to repeat any testimony we've
already heard thank you very
much
okay all right right um thank you all
for giving me this opportunity to speak
my name is Alexander manella I'm from we
New Hampshire and I'm here in support of
HB
1487 I'm not here to prove that that the
technology is harmful or dangerous I
believe this is um the hazards are
already established and I think the
Telecom corporations know this because
they take measures to protect their
workers from this technology
right um they done certain personal
protective equipment um when they do
maintenance on on it um there are
warning signs around a lot of this
equipment um when they do upgrades or
maintenance they shut the equipment down
before they send human beings up there
to to work on it so it's not I can't
tell you exactly how Hazard this
hazardous this technology is but there
is some risk that I think we should all
consider so I'm not going to repeat
anything I'm just going to focus on why
um I support this bill what I like about
it and then I'm going to speak to the
exhibit that I submitted so first of all
in terms of the amendments to RSA 12
kilo um the things I like about
this um it it promotes transparency and
that's really my main thing just being
transparent right before you release
this safe and effective technology tell
me why it's so safe and effective right
be transparent with us that's that's my
my only um ask here so some of the
recommendations were to provide an
update an upto-date map of exposure
levels locations of where this
technology has been deployed right so we
can see that to the public can see it
and it's readily available to us so I
like that I also like the the
recommendation to improve and
standardize signage for this technology
so for example I spent a lot of time in
Manchester and I see these 5G mini
Towers going up all around their eye
level with bedroom windows they're right
outside of
residences okay if it's safe it's safe
but I see little warning signs on them
and they're they're usually high up on
the utility pole small text not easily
legible kind of hard to see I think the
signage should be clear and apparent it
should be bright yellow large legible
and maybe even put it in braille right
there's some risk here that the public
needs to be aware of um so I like that
again for transparency the next thing I
like about this bill is taking
measurements and collecting data okay if
it's safe let's let's just show show us
that it's safe right there's a lot of
people that are concerned about it um so
take some measurements put the data out
there and then let the public decide um
help you know let us make informed
decisions as to whether or not we want
to be um around this so I I don't I
can't tell you what the effects are on
the human body of cellular radiation or
um you know RF technology I can't give
you you know what exactly happens but
let's measure it let's find out um and
and maybe um you know having really fast
wireless internet um outweighs the you
know the risks to human health right so
but put that out there um I'll move on
so section four the recommendations for
wireless carriers I see cellular panels
popping up like on the crazy iest things
it's everywhere there's panels on Office
Buildings and schools on uh it's it's
everywhere and then you have these 5G
mini Towers popping up in residential
areas I think we need to put some
limitations on where we put this stuff
um there was a recommendation for a 500
meter setback um in front of residences
businesses and schools so I think um
creating some limitations for Telecom
corporations to to adhere to would be U
beneficial as well so those are the
reasons I support the bill um I think
these recommendations most of them are
they're reasonable they are easily
enforcable and I I don't think a lot of
them are cost prohibitive either I think
we kind of overthink that a lot and then
there's things we can do to kind of
enforce these things easily um and I
know nothing is free but um I think it's
more important like the the cost of this
is less important than
um um giving corporations free reign
right and and it's more important that
we force organizations to be forthcoming
with information sorry for stumbling
there um and then lastly I just want to
refer you all to the exhibit that I
passed around all right so I submitted
this just to kind of show you what I
think the attitude is of some of the
Telecom corporations that roll out this
technology um it it seems to go
unchecked so what you're looking at here
it's a giant cell tower in Bedford New
Hampshire and it's not easily
recognizable usually because it's you
know in the summer and the spring it's
covered by trees and stuff but you know
in the winter you could see it pretty
clearly and it's located right by
Ridgewood nursing home and a 62 plus um
disabled Community like right in the
corner in the parking lot and um I I
don't know I just I think that's a
really peculiar place to put one of
these things and I wonder like you know
would any of you um want to live by this
or have it in your backyard or
um have your family near this um but you
know someone out there thought oh this
is like the perfect spot for one of
these antennas you have elderly people
here and um you know a nursing home here
these people are on their way out anyway
just put it here no one will ever notice
but I noticed it
um
so um that's that's mostly what I have
here um I understand cellular technology
is advancing I use a cell phone um I I
just think we need to have a little more
transparency on on this technology
that's all I'm asking for here not
Banning 5G I it's not ruining my life in
any way I just like the information to
be visible so we can make informed
decisions I'll leave it at that thank
you thank you we appreciate your
testimony representative Ms would like
to ask you a question thank you Mr chair
um and thank you for taking my question
um you know one of the things that I
thought I heard heard you advocate for
was signage explaining to people what
the the risks are um is there is there a
is there a
definitive study that you know you can
reference that would be referenced on
that signage to let people know that
there is a risk I personally don't have
one but there's existing signage up
there now right so there must be some
risk if the Telecom comp compes are
putting signs up there there's some
study out there I don't have I'm not an
expert there but you know clearly
there's a
hazard representative parshall has a
question yes thank you chair and thank
you for your testimony um you mentioned
if you were asking if people would like
to live near these cell to towers are
you aware of the decrease in property
values when these towers are placed near
residential areas yes do you have any
figures numbers on that I do not okay
would be surprised to hear they were 7.4
minimum 7.4% not surprised at
all okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you for thank you uh
talking to us here this morning and
since I have no more pink cards I'm
going to bring to a close the public
hearing on House Bill
1487 can uh I have filled out pardon I
just say one thing take a minute okay
well if if you fill out a pink card and
don't give it to me then I can't
possibly know that you want to
speak so I've already closed the public
hearing I'm sorry we're going to have to
uh I don't believe I Can Read just one
second I just want to remind everybody
you're made out of 70% water and water
is imprinted through radio waves the
bees they feel it more than we do and
these are very important factors of
what's going on here microwave works by
heating up the water vibrating the
molecules we're all dealing with way
more anxiety than we have over the last
years this is a big deal everybody think
about that
thanks okay
thanks next time you come to speak with
us please hand in your print card first
appreciate that okay now we're done and
uh so we're going to take a lunch break
and then we're going to come back at
1:30 for a full committee work session
and later this afternoon we're going to
have an exec session and I want to alert
the members of the
committee that the speaker and the clerk
are requesting that all committee
reports what we used to to call blurbs
be handed in to the chair before you
leave at the end of the day so if you
think that you might be writing a
committee report either a major majority
or Minority
Report think about how you can work on
that maybe during your lunch break or at
some other time so that you can get it
to me before you leave the building this
evening and you might want to confer
with your caucus leader if you're not
sure if you're going to be on the hook
for writing said report any reports that
I do not get before the close of
business um today will not be included
in the calendar and that's per the
speaker and the house
clerk so with that enjoy your lunch and
we'll see you at
1:30
work session on bills that we will
be moving to into executive session at
3:00
so we might as well take these in order
as they're listed in the scheduling
notice the first bill listed there is
House Bill 16 97-
FN the original title was suspending New
Hampshire's participation in emissions
reduction credit programs for a period
of two years we all know from the public
hearing that that was not the intent of
the
sponsors and that what they really
wanted to do was address some issues
raised by Forest carbon credit
programs
so in response to that public hearing I
went
to well first we had some uh internal
discussions and then I went to OS and
requested an amendment and Os
produced an amendment for
us it
is amendment number
224-0318 and I passed it out yesterday
to every
everyone and so I'm assuming that
everyone has a copy of
that I hope that's
correct am
again
2024 D
H so the name of the bill has been
changed to
relative to enrollment of forest land in
carbon
programs and the amendment replaces all
of the bill after the enacting
Clause with the text that you see on
lines 7 through 30th
30 since uh we didn't receive this
amendment until yesterday afternoon at
about 2 o' or
3:00 there was no way to really there
was no time really to figure out whether
this did what we wanted it to do until
after we completed
our public hearing work during the day
yesterday after we did complete that
work we looked at this amendment and
discovered that it doesn't actually do
what we wanted it to do
so as a result of that after we continue
our discussion here in a few
minutes when we get to exec session I'm
going to be calling I'm going to open
the exec session because it is a
scheduled meeting but then I'm
immediately going to call for a
recess now we're going
to have to move that exec session to
another date because we need an
amendment that actually works and is
actually
effective just doing an amendment that
doesn't do anything isn't
useful so we're going to spend another
week and I've got uh some folks like
Jason stock of the Timberland Owners
Association and some lobbyists like Dave
czy working on some new language that
will be
effective and attempt to address some of
the issues that this
bill has
raised so I'm I'm willing to have a
committee discussion right now about the
amendment that's before us even though
that will not be the final Amendment if
you guys want to otherwise we can move
on representative Harrington could you
give us like a brief summary or outline
of what this new Amendment to the
amendment's going to to do so we have
some idea of what to expect because I
mean if you say this there's there's a
bunch of things in this amendment I
clearly don't support so I'm wondering
if they're still going to be
there all right so the as the public
hearing revealed there's three basic
problems
that the sponsors of the bill are trying
to solve trying to resolve the first
problem is loss of Timber tax
revenue and section one of the amendment
that you have in front of you actually
addresses that issue by requiring the
Department of Revenue Administration
to develop rules to implement RSA 79
colon
5 and that will be part of the new
Amendment as
well where the problems arise are
the ru
making an establishment of a forest
registry the language that's here
doesn't really work from what I've been
told and so we need some new language
that will
work furthermore the very last section
of the amendment lines 27- 29 about
conservation easements I'm told
easements I'm told that that language
also is
probably not going to work for a lot of
people so we probably will delete that
section Al
together so what we'll end up with is an
amendment that has some new language
about creating a forest lands registry
that contains information about carbon
credit
programs what will it look like exactly
I'm not even sure at this point but
uh the goal will be to get this language
out soon enough so that all of us will
be able to study it and evaluate it for
multiple days before we have our next
work session and exec session on this
topic
because we feel and particularly house
leadership feels that this is an
important subject that we need to get
some some clear clarity about and so
we're going to try to do that before we
move forward
does that answer your question
representative
Harrington well it answers my question
but doesn't elay my concerns thank you
well this is a work station and there
are people in the room who will be
working on an amendment Amendment
language if you want to share your
concerns with them that might be
helpful well I guess my major concern
was I'm trying to figure I haven't read
this RSA 7 95 but I think it refers to
the rather archaic old law that says if
you don't cut down your Timber the towns
can tax you for not cutting it uh that's
a stupid law in my opinion shouldn't be
on the books if you own the property you
don't want to cut your Lumber down you
shouldn't have to and you shouldn't be
penalized for that by any stretch of
that and by putting in the bill to
develop new rules to do that I like I
say real problem with that okay good
that's good feedback representative ner
um have do we have copies of the
amendment or notes on it yes they were
passed out yesterday they were passed
out yesterday are there any extra copies
you
take I don't know if there were extra
copies Christie do you
know oh they're gone okay no extra
copies apparently
sorry any further discussion before we
representative Corman thank you um did
you list all the areas that we were
concerned about because there's
something that hasn't been mentioned
that at least I'm concerned about and
that is the effect on the support for
the timber industry the Mills the people
who transport Lumber and if Timber isn't
being cut then they are affected deeply
as well and as we heard during testimony
that throws into question the survival
of the Timber industry if the support
for the timber industry is not
viable thank you for remember
remembering that I had U I had not
forgotten it but I had forgotten to
mention
it
uh coming up with legislative language
to solve that problem
is probably outside the scope of what we
can do in the short term that sounds
like a a long-term problem that's going
to take some significant work to come up
with a solution if there even is a
solution because now you're talking
about the mar the market private markets
and uh whether government's going to try
to intervene in those markets that's a
tricky tricky subject as you well know
so the amendment may not be able to
address that issue but if we can address
the other
issues maybe we can get somewhere and
make some you know some significant
progress anybody
else
all right let's move on then from
1697 and now look at House Bill
1700 so
representative
Thomas Vice chair
Thomas has an amendment
for House Bill
1700 and what this amendment does
is
it repeals RSA 12- F which is a
weatherization statute that was placed
into the rsas back in
1985 nobody seems to know whether it's
ever been used but allows weather
modification and so
uh represent or vice chair Thomas
decided that it would be appropriate to
repeal that legislation since it's not
being used
anyway and so that would be the our plan
going forward you want to pass that out
dou or did you already do that I've
already passed it
around okay I haven't seen a copy but I
think extras
here thank you thank
you
so Doug do you want Vice chair Thomas
would you um speak to your Amendment
please yes well in the interest of
keeping it simple we looked at you know
the overall Bill and a lot of that bill
was unworkable or or areas that were
sort of uh hard to substantiate uh
certainly to put into effect but the one
area that seemed to be something that
had some good good purpose was that U
ancient RSA that no one seems to
remember ever having it been enacted and
certainly it's not something that we
were particularly wanted to do at this
time so at the very least uh to get this
thing rolling uh we felt that um having
a simple deletion of that RSA was at
least one step in in the direction of
something we could get done this year so
that's why we did
it
comments representative Corman thank you
um so I'm actually looking at the
RSA and the RSA says any department or
agency of the state may with the
approval of the governor and Council and
within the limits of appropriated funds
or by means of gifts Etc engage in and
undertake experimentation in the
techniques and methods for weather
modification and may cooperate therein
with the federal government with
authorized agencies of other states and
with interested persons and
organizations and then it goes on to
list some guard rails some conditions so
what I'm wondering is if we repeal this
we're repealing any guard rails that are
in place and I don't know of any
language anywhere that says that uh
whether modification may not happen so
if there isn't language anywhere that
says it may not happen it maybe I'm
wrong maybe there is some somewhere but
if there isn't language that says it may
not happen seems like then maybe it may
happen and we're removing the guard
rails and I'm just a little concerned
about that I certainly agree with the
the spirit of trying to fix this but I'm
just a little concerned about throwing
out the baby with the bath
water in your reading of the RSA is it
your sense that this applies to
governmental weather
modification yes I mean it just says any
department or agency of the state it
doesn't say anything about anybody else
so if we remove the Authority for the
state to engage in weather
modification I think that would make a
lot of people
happy I mean my comment was I don't know
if if we have anywhere that says the
state may
not well if we're removing the Authority
for the state to do it then how would
the state do it if it was
gone
I see your your point you're trying to
say should we forbid the state from
doing this but that's a different
question than just repealing
this particular RSA representative
Harrington um one of the things I'd be
curious about this I don't know if
anybody knows this uh RSA was written
some time ago has any department or
agency ever applied to the executive
Council for approval for weather
modification because that may be a good
way of getting a handle on this if it's
never been used then the maybe it just
becomes a useless law um that would be
something we could look at I do have to
agree with the representative saying
that if you just repeal it then does it
mean well then any Department can do
whatever they want because there's no
prohibition and that's sort of a long
fuzzy uh legal road to go down because
you have to look exactly what their
duties are and so forth that I probably
want to avoid but I think first could we
find out has any department or agency
ever apply to the the executive Council
for approval to do weather modifications
it's got to be a record of it somewhere
if it was
done representative nter thank you
during the hearing um some people
testified about um there being aluminum
being sprayed and um I don't know what
that if it's really being sprayed or not
but what I do know and I brought this in
for informational purposes is that
aluminum is in vaccines and vaccines
aluminum has been implicated as a Cause
of brain damage suspected factor in
Alzheimer's disease dementia seizures
and Comas allergic reactions can occur
on skin there's also a note that when
babies are hours or days old is
impossible to know if they have an
allergy so I just wanted to to put that
out there um that
aluminum it's it's everywhere including
the
shots okay thank you represent Vice
chair Thomas yes thank you Mr chair
getting back to uh representative
Harrington's um comments I believe if I
recall correctly we heard during
testimony that at least to the best of
their recollection no one there at the
time and and no state agency could ever
recall this RSA being enacted or to be
used although we didn't do an extensive
investigation Research into it uh the
people that were here at the time said
that they were unaware of it ever being
enacted so that's our basis for
this representative Thomas yes thank you
um I I I'm hearing that it's an older
law um and that it it may not be
effective but I'm wondering why it was
put in place in the first place does
anybody have any of that history why did
we create this
law I have no idea I don't recall if we
asked that question during the public
hearing but representative nter do you
know the answer no but I'm wondering if
it was a rule put in place because um
going just to compare going back um I
don't know to 2011 there was um we
repealed a bill uh we repealed a law
that was never voted on by the
legislature it was put in place by the
department of fishing game as a rule and
that happens a
lot rules are different from from state
law okay yeah they're completely
different yes um Chris
could you see if you could do some
research to find out why that law was
passed RSA
12f
okay we'll see what you can find out for
now and if you find anything let us know
if you don't then we'll we have options
this is a proposed amendment we don't
have to adopt this amendment
if we don't adopt this amendment then
we'll have to make another judgment
about what to do with this bill
representative
PL thank you chair uh in the previous uh
testimony there was no mention they did
re they claim they did research on this
and even there's no mention of the
federal authorities who's supposed to
report to the state agency have making
any um notice of spraying so whatever so
I think it has been looked into um I'm
sure if there was it would have been
brought forth during that
testimony so apparently this uh statute
was modified in
2021 modified but I don't know what the
modification
was
I have that in my okay so apparently
this was modified by a bill filed by
representative Judy Aaron in 2020 or
2021 yes and it was there was a uh an
article in the newspaper that I printed
which was in my book and I probably
can't put my hands on it immediately but
it was basically the bill was passed to
make sure that there would be notice
required in the state of New Hampshire
um so there is language in here about
disclosing to the public the chemical
compounds and Technologies to be used in
proposed weather
modification
Etc okay any further comments uh
representative
Thomas um and I I don't see that
modified bill from 2021 but um
who gives the the uh notification of of
something and has notification ever been
given out to the
public according to the language of the
statute
I mean I'm going to assume it's Dees
because they've got an air division the
department or agency of the state
participating in such engagement or
experimentation shall do the following
place a public notice in at least four
newspapers within the state and on the
departmental internet website informing
the public of the date and type of the
proposed weather modification program or
experimentation events within the state
do that answer your question well
the follow-up was or not the followup
but the other part of my question was
has that ever been
done has Dees ever or or the agency ever
put
for have have they gone through this
mechanism or is it just they're in case
someday since it is an an existing state
law I would surmise that if any
department has engaged in this activity
they would have followed the law and
notified the public do I know of any
instance where that's happened I do
not yep representative PL uh thank you
chair
um maybe to answer this question I just
want to bring the chair's attention
there's another amendment in for
1700 and the sponsor representative
Penza is in the audience maybe she if
the chair would like to ask she could
have have done research or know of
research done on that just to bring it
to your attention thank you okay thank
you representative muns Mr chair I I I
just did a little search and there was a
bill passed in 2021 HB
128 which added section two to the RSA
as we see it now previous to um that
bill passing the only things on the
books the only thing on the books was
section
one it's HB 128 passed in 202
one so section two is all about
disclosure and public input that bill
added all the disclosure requirements
okay thank you for looking that up
appreciate that representative
Kaplan yeah Mr chair just to answer the
question about the dees and and their
knowledge about these programs when when
we had the dees uh Comm I believe he was
the commissioner of the air Resources
Division he was in here testifying I
asked him do you have you known of any
such programs of experimentation taking
place at the federal level and he said
no not that his not so I mean I'm
assuming that that would also cover any
cooperating sort of weather
experimentation that was done by any
Department his
department so just I wanted to offer
that so representative Corman were was
section two of the statute the guard
rails that you spoke of earlier okay yes
further
discussion
so how do you guys want to proceed do
you want to consider this amendment at
an executive session or take some other
action on this
bill any
comment representative liwicki I'm in
favor of uh adopting the
amendment thank
you anyone else have preferences
representative parshall uh can we
specify which amendment I assume we're
talking about uh uh representative
Thomas's uh Amendment but I just want to
make sure
that's yeah it's 202
24305 okay thank
you any further representative Kaplan I
I suppose I just want to Echo
representative corman's uh hesitance
about just eliminating this uh section
12f colon one given that it it adds the
guard rails of notification and uh
public input public it solicits public
input regarding any proposed weather
modification program um which seems to
me that that's sort of what the original
sponsors of the bill intended in the
first place is to have some sort of
guard rails around any future weather
modification
experimentation okay representative MC
Williams thank you shair v um this has
been a really helpful conversation and
I'm glad we're having a work session on
the proposed amendment I think that we
may be able to take a little bit of a
more uh moderated TCT instead of
repealing this uh provision altogether
if we were to put a moratorium on this
provision for a certain number of years
say two years to give some time to look
into this I think that it would be
appropriate seeing as we don't have any
evidence that this is actually being
used but there is evidence that as of
2021 there was a second piece added to
the RSA on the books to make sure that
there's disclosure so the section one is
really the portion I think we could put
a a two-year hold on and just say we
cannot for the next two years and then
it would be repealed after that period
of time rather than completely repealing
this out of whole cloth and removing an
RSA thank you interesting idea
representative
Harrington yeah you my I I share the
concern it's been stated because uh we
don't know if this has been used at all
maybe it was put in and it was never
used we don't know why someone opted in
2021 at least not the president as to
why they thought it was necessary to put
those additional disclosure things in
there were was it being used and it
wasn't being disclosed to the public th
those are questions I think we need to
answer because before we just repeal
this we got to figure out if it's really
necessary to have some controls on that
so I would opt that we wait a little bit
on this I know it's a uh it's an FN bill
so it's a it's an early bill but I think
we could wait another few days or till
next week and find out has is there any
record of the executive Council
approving a weather modification has any
Department ever had any record of
requesting it and why was the uh 2021
Bill written something must have
prompted that not just someone going
through the rsas and saying boy it'd be
nice to have public disclosure on
weather modifications so I I just think
we should give it a little bit more time
before we make a decision whether to
repeal it or leave it as
is oh I don't think unfortunately that
we have said time I think we have to
make a decision today this is an early
bill so we have to decide what we're
going to do we could amend
it as has been offered here the other
option would be to itl the
bill so we have to decide what we want
to do between now and 3 o'cl
representative Thomas yes um Just In
fairness and I know it was mentioned
earlier there has been another amendment
that that was sent regarding 1700 and I
I do think that that should be included
in the disc
discussion I haven't seen another
amendment
so I I believe I got mine yesterday
yeah excuse me where was that
distributed yes representative PL uh
Carrie had at the last moment got
permission to from uh representative
prends this hand this out it was after
the close of the meeting some I have U
more copies for those who have not
received
it okay I was just handed a copy it's
Amendment
07h and it amends the bill
by replacing the original bill with all
this new
text so representative Thomas since you
brought this to our ition why don't you
discuss this proposed amendment yay me
uh well I I do find the this this
particular amend Amendment problematic
um but I do think it deserves a
discussion um just some general points
um line six the general court finds that
many atmospheric activities such as
weather modification blah blah blah
there where are the statistics where are
the reports for that you can't just
claim that that those
um activities are harming human health
safety environment we can infer but you
can't claim
um oh yeah so uh line 11 we we it talks
about intentionally polluting which is a
little different from weather seeding or
cloud seeding activities in New
Hampshire's atmosphere at or at ground
level so now we've introduced crop
spraying I guess is for for lack of a
better
word um so so that's problematic um on
line 13 preserve the safe healthful and
peaceful
uses I don't know if there's a legal
definition for peaceful uses but I think
that's problematic I could go on but but
um I just I just think that this this
amendment representative Penza put some
work into it and I just think we should
be discussing
it okay further comment on the
amendment that was just handed out
amendment
number
H representative
Harrington well the amendment looks like
it was taken from some kind of a
template from some kind of a national uh
effort and um I think people put a lot
of work into this it just doesn't really
fit New Hampshire I mean first of all
assigns all sorts of Duties to the
county sheriff who doesn't is not
involved in any type of uh environmental
laws or enforcing them or figuring them
out uh it talks about All State climate
related appointees must have been or
administered the oath of office I don't
know that we have any climate related
appointees I don't know even what the
term means and if we did have them they
would have already been administered an
oath of office um and then we have the
sheriff reporting into the military
Affairs and veteran services and they're
supposed to do some kind of tracking
with software or something and so forth
and then the sheriff shall issue a cease
and assist order upon notification that
their discovery of stratospheric aerosol
injection cloud seeding weather
modification or other atmospheric
polluting activity it doesn't say what
those activities are it just says
polluting activity well you know that's
open to a lot of interpretation it
doesn't say any limits on it doesn't say
any you can you can do you cannot use
this material uh this is banned in in
these quantities so I mean it's just it
just isn't it's just not ready for prime
time but any stretch the imagination
so Vice chair Thomas has a comment thank
Mr chair I I would agree with the last
two Representatives this amendment
presents even more questions than the
the amendment I proposed and since this
is an ear bill um I couldn't support
this this amendment if we if we um have
some doubts about the amendment that I
proposed then since this is an early
bill then absence of that I think the
best course of action would be to just
itail this bill to make sure that we
don't undo any guard rails until until
we look into it so that's that's um one
course we can take now further comment
representative fog uh thank you chair
um work to working off um represent
Wendy
Thomas's concern that if we have a
committee work
section the sponsor if there is any
documentations can present it to us so
we can see and that might bring up why
the second part in 2021 was added as you
said it must be a reason and we can
actually ask
for legitimate concise
documentation so this bill this
amendment could someday be Rewritten
thank
you further
comments representative
Kennedy uh thank you I mean going back
to um Doug Thomas's
amendment can we can we you know pass
that Amendment repeal that law and then
if we want to we can introduce a law
that would prohibit you know weather
modification so I did receive a an
email from Warren M Perry who is the
Deputy agitant
general of the Department of military
Affairs and Veterans Services and he
says we do not and cannot support the
provisions requiring us to review
reported violative flights using flight
tracking software to determine time and
location of the plane's passage page two
lines 15 through
20 we are also concerned about the
requirement to issue notice to federal
agencies page two lines 28 to
30 our air traffic control operations
are fully funded by the federal
government and support of federal
missions and conducted by the New
Hampshire National Guard we cannot
support these requirements in a
federally funded status compliance with
these requirements will require those
National Guard personnel and our
equipment to be ordered into State
service by the governor per RSA
110-b col
so that would seem to be a negative of
this
particular Amendment further discussion
question representative McGee so Mr
chair based on the information you just
provided does that mean that we're back
to representative Thomas's Amendment and
the disposition that we're trying to
come up with for whether we're going to
adopt or itl that
Amendment yes I or actually
representative MC Williams had a third
option right which was a moratorium on
part one until we could determine if
there were changes that needed to be
made to 12f is that right so if we were
going to consider a moratorium on part
one we would need language do you have
language representative
McWilliams I'm happy to scratch
something out and send it to OS before
we EXA if you'd
like okay why don't you do that and when
you get something please uh share it
with the rest of us and we'll decide if
we want to pursue that or not
representative
PL thank you chair um in that
moratorium it does no good if there is
no work
session of this committee to see what
the reason is just by having moratorium
we don't look at for we need to set up
some sort of Comm committee to look into
it from my perspective thank
you well do you have a suggestion
then
um if uh represented
mcams is willing if she could add
in a b po spin uh work session from this
committee to look at any documentations
or whatever
of during that moratorium do we continue
it was there a
reason or even bring it back it might be
a reason we need to have that but
without documentation and calling in um
testimony I'm not sure where moror would
just
still well here's another
option we could just refer this bill
from interim study for interim study and
then this committee can spend several
hours next fall looking at it and
deciding what to
do any reaction representative
fog yes with dual diligence and um
consideration from the chair I was asked
do testimony at another committee may be
excused you can thank you thank you
representative Thomas
um I I'm not necessarily opposed to
moratorium I just don't know if we
recognize that there will be unintended
consequences from the reading that
representative Corman read out it
mentioned Federal and other states if if
I heard it correctly and and so are we
cutting off relations with with the
federal government and other states
completely by by repealing this for this
for this topic
anyway possibly so yeah I think that's
which might be another reason to put
this bill into interim study
yeah representative bney thank you
chairman um so this my understanding is
section one is the part that's been on
the book since
1985 so it seems like it's been on the
books for that long it hasn't been used
2year moratory
is there is there something happening in
the next two years or what's what's all
of the sudden after 1985 uh that would
be my question you are not and it's a
good
one represent Vice chair Thomas yes Mr
chair um uh all good suggestions but I'm
looking at the original bill and the one
of the proposed amendments and the
discussion we've had
here I don't believe I uh interim study
is going to really result in any Earth
shattering change uh a new bill uh next
year maybe uh with some thought into it
but if we if we do an itl then we're
basically leaving the president language
intact preserving the guard rails and so
um try the moratorium to the previous
representative's Point may give us some
time to come up with the same conclusion
I'm not sure uh if we don't enact the
amendment to do away with the entire RSA
which I can see some points about what
about why we may not then a simple itl
leaves that RSA intact at least until
maybe at some other time a different
language might uh might come up so
otherwise I think is uh is not going to
give us
much okay well what regardless of what
we decide in executive session we're
done with this for now because uh we're
going to suspend this work session at
2:45 for a Republican caucus so we need
to move on to the other bills on the
schedule if you want to discuss them
before the executive session so how
about we discuss HB
1036 and an amendment prepared by
representative Harrington
indicated that there was a lack of
flexibility provided to the Public
Utilities Commission by the language and
the
original um statute and while
representative Harrington and I both
love
Simplicity
striking uh the words for the purpose of
March 21st 2022
filing or maybe it was future plans
offerings I forget exactly what it
struck but while that was simple and
elegant it was true Draconian in terms
of what it meant for the rest of the
statute so this amendment does provide
some flexibility to the commission going
forward but does not invalidate or uh
allow the commit the commission to
ignore the granite state
test when it does its future
deliberations on this topic so I think
this is a good amendment I I uh like the
fact that it provides additional
flexibility to the commission but keeps
the granite state test intact for the
uh as the primary test along with the
addition of the Total Resource cost as a
secondary test for evaluating these cost
Effectiveness
programs
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
can I take a look at your language
because I can't put my hand on it thank
you um I I understand the explanation
that you gave I think that that's uh you
know a reasonable start point for a
discussion but the amendment as written
um basically the language that I would
take exception with says the commission
may approve modifications to the granite
state
test um or adopt different or additional
tests
and uh prior to the commencement of any
trianium period after 2027 so I I
actually think that substantively this
language is the same as the original
bill in that it's providing the Pu with
the ability to modify the granite state
test um in order
to uh I I don't know secure specific
outcomes I guess the granite state test
to my understanding and I had a
conversation with um with Mr LCA about
this it was sort of it was a there were
long discussions and it was kind of a
hard one set of a
calculation uh that was agreed upon by
all parties including the Pu and this
language basically says that they can
change it so they don't have to use it
as is um and that's what we were trying
to avoid I think the test that we heard
in um in the
hearings uh there were quite a few
people who
opposed uh allowing the Pu to not use
the the granite state test as it was
intended and the discussions around
outcomes uh not being the same had
everything to do with the inputs that
they were using and not necessarily the
formula that is the granite state test
so maybe we should educate the committee
uh further on what the granite state is
and isn't because I think what this
language does is say if the commission
wants to change the granite state test
it can and I would be opposed to
that representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair
um yes although this bill permits the
revision of the grand state test it says
that it must be done uh pursu to a um
agative process and it has to be done 18
months before any new test is going to
be used so you certainly have an
opportunity to understand what changes
are being made and why they're being
made uh and if they're relevant or if
they're problematic so um as I remember
the testimony one of the biggest factors
was uh um what is the appropriate
discount rate to be used and and uh you
know I I think that is a relevant point
of discussion and if it has to be
discussed 18 months before you make that
change I don't I don't see a a big
concern here may I respond yes I think I
would agree with uh representative
Bernardi that the language clearly says
that any change that they make has to be
through an adjudicative
process and the order issued no less
than 18 months prior to the beginning of
the trianium period so um I I think your
objection is is that this is essentially
the same bill is not accurate um well
let me explain the sentence says the
commission may approve modifications to
the granite state test or adopt
different additional tests prior to the
commencement of any triangual period
beginning with the program and shall do
so by order of so with this language
they can adopt different or additional
tests prior to the commencement of any
trianium period if it goes through an
adjudicative proceeding but where the
where the or comes in it the first half
of the sentence gives the commission the
approval of
modifications so I I don't I don't see
the the remainder of the sentence on
developed through a judicative process I
don't see that as modifying the original
part of the sentence because it's an
either or well that's clearly what it
says it says that the granite state test
or modifications made to the granite
state test or different or additional
tests prior to the commencement of the
of the
program shall uh it shall do so by order
provided that any change is developed
through an adjudicate itive process so
the order is the result of the Jud
judicative process that's the only way
you can make a change we have an English
M that's not what it says who should
comment on
this
yeah okay representative kman you have a
comment uh I I do but it's not not about
the um the either or um I my concern is
that uh yes it would be through an
adjudicative process but who who are the
adjudicators is it not the Pu they so
they they could say well we think we
want this other test and then they
adjudicate yeah we're going to use this
other test so the legislatur then
seeding the authority of what test it is
really just to the
Pu uh repres representative Harrington
wants to speak on his Amendment thank
you first of all the gron state test did
not come down from the mount with the
Ten Commandments it was developed by the
puc in the late teens with input from
all sorts of different groups and people
and it was a lot of work there was
outside Consultants were brought in it
was reports written and eventually it
was decided upon as the way to go at
that time by the time this would kick in
this amendment most of that analysis
would be pushing 10 years old and all
this says it's the same people that
approved the granted state test the same
people that went through that process
and well the same organization that came
up with it uh turned around and now
you're going to say they can never
change that again unless we change the
law that simply isn't the way we do
things I mean we if you go to the Pu why
have them if they can't change uh
something when circumstances change we
allow them to change rates all the time
now I know ever Source likes it staying
the way it is could simpler for them and
the utilities they don't have to change
everything they can do it exactly the
same way they did last year next year
and the year after and the year after
but that might not necessarily be the
best way all this allows is that the
people that get nominated by the
governor and approved by the executive
counsil to be Public Utilities
Commissioners can go through an
adjudicative process that is totally
open to the public the consumer Advocate
would be there testifying members of
this committee could testify members
from the utilities could testify people
from clean New Hampshire could testify
they'd all have input in in standing on
this process and then they would allow
the process to come to folish a second
time maybe they would use the exact same
test the granted State uh test maybe
they would make no changes but maybe
circumstances would say it's best to
make some changes this simply allows the
flexibility for them to do that and
remember if the legislature really hated
what they did they could always come
back the next year and change the law
and say no you can't do that but I think
we don't don't want ra those type of
regulations on that technical matters
that you're dealing with here with very
very heavy details this committee is not
the place to do that level just like we
don't do rate cases here because it's a
very very complicated uh economics
physics engineering legal and the great
place to do that is the Pu that's why we
have
them representative
McGee just the thought that I had in
looking at this is that there was no
case made as to as to what is wrong with
the granite state test right so what
we're doing is we're saying we're going
to eliminate the granite state test or
allow it to be modified to be something
other than the granite state test and
there may or may not be uh an
adjudicative proceeding to to to regroup
around what that new iteration would be
but we haven't established that we are
throwing the baby out with the bath
water for any particular reason right we
did establish in the hearings at least
we heard in in the hearings from the
consumer Advocate that that there was a
dislike of the granite state test by a
particular commissioner and that if they
were allowed to modify or do away with
the test that they would do so and so
from our standpoint as legislators I
think we should be looking at whether or
not the granite state test has stood the
test of time and if we don't understand
well enough about what it is and what it
isn't then we shouldn't be asking for it
to be eliminated when we have no idea
what it will be replaced with because it
seems like that is an arbitrary position
whereas at least all the players right
now know what the granite state test is
and they're they're well used to it
could I respond please Mr chairman okay
representative Harrington yeah well
first of all I don't think we should be
getting into uh the policies or
personalities of who's on the Pu and who
hasn't whoever's on there has been
nominated by the governor and approved
by the executive councel and most of the
people are there now's terms will be up
well before 2027 so if you really want
to change them out there's a way to do
that but I don't think it's bringing
their opinions like that up someone says
they think some pu Commissioners against
it I think it's a slight to the
commission so and the second thing this
only allows the commission to do what it
does constantly we do this all the time
they're going to do this a couple of
times this year they're going to be
setting rates we don't come in here and
say oh we'll set the rate the default
service rate and you got to stay with
that methodology to set it and you can't
change it ever even if things
drastically change all this does is give
them flexibility to make changes if and
when they feel they're necessary and
through an full full judicative process
which will take months of public
hearings testimony and everything you
can think of with people coming in
experts from all different sides and all
different opinions it's a very detailed
thorough process and we just all I'm
saying on this is I think they've
requested and I think that they should
have the flexibility to relook at this
we shouldn't be dictating something of
this technical a nature to the specifics
for the Pu that's why we have a
pu representative
reels thank you Mr chairman I just want
to speak up uh in support of uh
representative McGee's main contention
that um you know this bill and the
amendment to this bill is premised on
the idea that there's something wrong
with the way that Energy Efficiency
programs in this state uh are evaluated
and I want to refer back to
representative Harrington's comments
about how is uh you know very apt
description of
how the granite state test was developed
through a very lengthy
involved deliberative
consultative
process you know just five six years ago
and this is let's remember what this is
all
about this is all about how the state of
New
Hampshire makes a judgment about the
cost
effectiveness of our present investment
and future or or if you want present
cost and future benefit
of you know I'll call them micro
investments in Energy Efficiency
right we Levy the systems benefits
charge we support the New Hampshire
saves
programs thousands of projects are are
uh completed every year throughout the
state and investing in lighting upgrades
and insulation installation and things
like that and so this whole debate about
Granite State tests cost effect it's all
about present cost future benefits so a
lot of work was put in
um by many parties to come up with with
a formula and that's what the granite
state test is a Formula methodology for
making that evaluation now as the years
go by it's certainly possible in fact
it's likely that the uh values that are
used in the calculations pursuant to the
formula might change from five six years
ago to now through next but I really
don't think
that every five years the legislature
needs to pass a law and direct you know
let's let's go back and and rehash the
whole debate about cost effectiveness of
investments in Energy Efficiency
programs uh in in something as uh I'll
call it obscure to the public as a pu uh
adjudicative process uh it's just not
necessary um I we are the state that in
New England that invests by far the
least in um in these in these Energy
Efficiency programs uh and and you know
we've got to a point finally 5 years ago
and I thought people thought you know
even as late as two years ago where we
had bipartisan agreement on the modest
Investments that we would make each year
but still we have a bills doing this
that are kind of oh let's go back and
and re-evaluate and and and evaluate the
methodology I just don't think it's
necessary I oppose the amendment I'm
going to oppose the bill okay good thank
you
so where did the granite state test come
from it came from an adjudicative
process at the
Pu and this amendment wants to give the
Pu the flexibility to make changes to
the granite state test through an
adjudicative process it's exactly the
same
thing as what came up with the test to
begin
with I I just don't see why this would
be considered to be a problem
but obviously we're not going to uh
agree on this one so let's move on and
take a look at House Bill
1078 so this uh amendment to House Bill
1078 2024
0301 H was submitted by representative
Bernardi and it fairly substantially
changes U how this
bill approached this
subject initially or originally so
representative Bernardi could you give
us an explanation for how do this change
would work am y this was distributed
yesterday
01h
so if you remember this bill initially
was uh
to give uh First Responders a priority
spot on the top of
uh
communication uh Towers to uh deal with
essentially black holes or gaps in
communication that occur in many
communities
um and uh in that hearing the uh
Department of Safety uh suggested that
was not a good approach for multiple
reasons uh but suggested that uh
engineering study should be done to
identify where those gaps were and that
uh that all good uh telecommunications
folks would be just delighted to provide
uh spots to deal with these problems if
appropriate kind Communications were
held um so an initial draft of this
amendment followed that approach but
then that was subsequently reviewed uh
with the Department of Safety and they
somewhat changed their mind um and so uh
I think it was largely because the cost
of them doing engineering studies to
identify where the gaps were um and what
the potential opportunities for filling
them were would would be a uh a head
count that they did not have in the
department at that time and it's not in
the current budget and therefore um we
needed to come up with a different
approach so the approach is to uh have
them investigate these uh the gaps
without doing formal engineering studies
and then come up with
recommendations uh on strategies of how
how this problem could be addressed
addressed in future
legislation okay so that's the amendment
representative Thomas has a comment yes
I do um I believe in giving credit where
credit is due and I think that this
amendment is a good
solution thank you representative
Ms guess I have a question for
representative Bernardi as I read the
amendment um it's still in it it it
still leaves in place section one of the
original bill
yeah correct it doesn't change the
current statute at all the only thing
that's new is section two which was
where the original bill was focused as
well um so I I haven't we haven't done
anything with the Emergency Management
powers and duties of uh regarding
communication systems that's current
statutory
language uh just just follow up yes the
original bill in section one included
paragraph B which is new
language that talks about U the priority
that that that grants the uh First
Responders the top 20 feet right well
okay so in the rewrite that is that has
been put as sub paragraph two but that's
not what the amendment says the
amendment says it's
adding the new section two after section
one in the original bill and the
original Bill section one includes subp
paragraph
B yes but that's not that's not what the
amendment says
okay so representative McGee I didn't
hear what you said because you didn't
turn on your mic I'm sorry yeah I just
was looking at the original Bill and
noticing that that section B was the
part that had the upper 20 feet which
was PL perceived to be problematic so I
think that part was stricken and
replaced by the new language that they
wanted to add is that correct yes that
is
correct but again that's not what the
bill says I don't
believe it says amend the
bill so it's the original bill after
section
one the follow and the following and
renumbering the original section two to
read is number three section one in the
original Bill includes subparagraph
B so it needs to be deleted so so you're
speaking of lines six and seven though
those appear to be an
error
yes you need to get rid of
16 is the intent that this would replace
section one altoe or just replace uh
paragraph B paragraph B replace
paragraph B that's what it should say
yeah all right I'm sorry I focused in
only on the amend language I didn't
focus in on the Preamble stuff at the
top all right so amend the bill by
inserting after section one the
following and ruming the original
section two to read as
three I believe it should delete
paragraph b in section one
right and then just add this as SE the
new section
too have delete paragraph
B and re the original section two to
and reum the
original and
renumber section
two not the
originaly has
com representative
rney all right we know what needs to be
done so yes representative thank you if
I may be so picky um if you look at the
original Bill line three also has a very
small change where it adds a paragraph a
and if we're removing paragraph B then
we need to also remove the little a for
paragraph
a
okay you know what that
means I have to get the
yeah
okay did you have a comment
representative
Kennedy the amendment has no effective
date because the effective date is on
the bill
itself representative Berney uh thank
you chairman I was just going to add
would it make sense to just have the uh
language B uh amend everything after the
encant clause and just have that be
because that's the only change right in
this in this amendment so just have the
whole bill replaced with what's in the
amendment that would potentially work
yeah representative Corman thank you I
have one other question um the amendment
says that uh the there would be a report
issued to the general court usually when
I see these bills it lists various
officers in the general court that
reports go to and I'm just wondering if
this should be like those
other
bills you mean the speaker of the house
and the president of the speaker
president of the Senate the clerk
yes the general court is led by those
people
so I would guess if I was going to
deliver this report that who I'd send it
to
but it is a good it is a good um catch I
think
so has anybody seen chrisy recently just
want we're going to need to have
somebody um contact OS she's researching
cloud seating she's researching what
she's researching cloud seating oh cloud
seating
right all right well while we have a
minute you know since we're going to
need to make some changes to this
amendment let's talk very very briefly
about hb1
1472 relative to rebates for Energy
Efficiency funds for electric
vehicles representative Ms I think has
an amendment right so let's take a look
at
that and then we're going to have to
wrap this up pretty
quickly
would you like me to speak to
it yes please okay um so this
uh this amendment is the um kind of the
official version of what I had
circulated
yesterday um and what this amendment
does is attempts to uh Place some
guidelines and guard rails around the
program that we discussed in the uh
hearing when the bill was
introduced um as as the bill is
currently structured all it does is talk
about a $3 million program to be
administered by Doe or and and instructs
doe to create a pilot program what this
amendment does is specifies what that
pilot program would look like
um one of the significant changes that
has been made uh there are a couple
significant changes one of them is that
rather than have doe administer the
program um we um are recommending that
the Department of Revenue Administration
be the administrator of the program
which was um a great surprise to the
representatives from the Department of
Revenue Administration who are with us
here today
um and the the rationale behind that was
that um Dr is in the business of sending
out checks to people uh in terms of you
know tax refunds Etc so it felt we felt
like they would have the um at least if
not the infrastructure of the mindset to
be able to uh administer a program like
this the other significant program is uh
change is that um I can't I can't
remember representative MC Williams when
the original effect date was but we
decided to push it out to July 1st of
2025 to give the Department of Revenue
Administration some time to get the
program uh
organized uh it would be a two-year
program $1.5 million doll each each of
the two years the department would be
able to deduct from that 1.5 million any
administrative costs associated with the
program at the end of the two-year
program they would be um requested to um
submit a report report to um the house
committee and the senate committee so
that we could evaluate whether it made
sense moving forward um in terms of the
actual specifics of the
program um it it follows um it follows
the federal
guidelines in terms of what kinds of
vehicles would be Avail would be
eligible um the eligible Vehicles would
be um pickup trucks sport utility
vehicles and vans up that cost up to
$80,000 and uh $50,000 for all other
eligible Vehicles cars Etc um there
would be a um incentive payment
available for of $2,000 for battery
electric
vehicles and 1,000 for a plug-in hybrid
vehicle uh and that would be available
on both used and new cars uh it would be
um anyone any New Hampshire resident
with a new with a New Hampshire driver's
license over the age of 18 would be
eligible for one incentive payment per
vehicle per
year um and there is a income test that
is consistent with the federal
guidelines um 300,000 for a married
couple 225 for heads of household and
150 for other
filers the program would be set up in
such a way that um the rebate would be
offered to the individual at the
dealership and the individual would then
have the ability to decide whether they
wanted to receive the rebate themselves
or assign it transfer it to the
dealership and then the dealer would
take it off the the sticker
price
um I think that's
it thank you very much any comments on
this
uh Amendment proposed Amendment seeing
none I'm going to call this work session
uh to a
conclusion and uh ask that the room be
cleared so that the Republicans can have
a caucus we will re reassemble here at 3
o' for an exec session thank you very
much
so I'm going to open an executive
session on House Bill 16 97- FN
suspending New Hampshire's participation
in emissions reduction credit programs
for a period of two years as I discussed
um earlier in the day due to the fact
that the amendment that we received
yesterday afternoon from os does not do
the job we want it to do we are going to
recess
this executive session until a future
date which will be noticed in the
calendar and we will take up a new
Amendment for House Bill
1697 so this executive SE executive
session is officially
recessed now I would like to to open a p
an executive session on House Bill 1700
FN prohibiting the intentional release
of polluting emissions including cloud
seating weather modification excessive
electromagnetic radio frequency and
microwave radiation and making penalties
for violation of such prohibition and I
recognize representative Vice chair
Thomas for a motion thank you Mr chair I
motion itl on HP 1700 chair recognizes
represent sentive Bernardi I second the
motion moved and seconded that we itl HB
1700 FN is there any
discussion representative MC
Williams uh thank you chair Bose just to
follow up on the conversation we had
during our work session um I did put in
a request to OS to do a um Amendment for
a moratorium for two years to give us
more time to get information on um first
what has been requested requested since
1985 from the executive Council and uh
Department of energy and second uh is
there more information that we need in
order to make a decision whether or not
to move forward with this I just feel as
though we're looking for more data uh so
I think an amendment for a moratorium
could give us more time to get more data
uh that being said I I respect the
committee's decision on how we end up on
this I just wanted to give everyone an
update thank you thank you
representative MC Williams if the itl
motion should fail maybe we'll consider
your potential Amendment Is there
further
discussion representative Vice chair
Thomas uh in terms of my it motion uh we
just discuss the fact that there are a
lot of uncertainties uh the bill as as
was originally submitted uh was
completely unworkable amendments seem to
try to address part of it but there was
still
uncertainty uh we think that you know if
if something else can come up it should
be in a new bill the following year uh
and so therefore um uh itl I think it's
the appropriate motion for this
time further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of itl for HB 1700
FN Vice chair Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative Ley yes representative
Bry yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL
no representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee
yes representative MC Williams
no representative crean yes
Representative
paral
no representative Kaplan yes
representative muns yes representative
Noel yes representative Thomas yes
representative Corman
yes representative rolds yes chairman
Vose
yes okay uh
163 16-3 by a vote of 16 to3 the
committee adopts the motion of itl on HB
FN Vice chair Thomas will write the
majority report will there be a Minority
Report seeing none there will be no
Minority
Report I need that majority report
before the end of the day before uh
anyone
leaves or at least before
clarification is the end of the day uh
just asking 449 44 we've been instructed
by house committee services to try to
leave this building by 5:00 every
afternoon because the employees who work
here have to stay until we leave
so from this point forward let's
consider five o'l to be the end of the
day and uh but for the purposes of
submitting a majority or a Minority
Report you you stay if you're assigned
to do that you stay here until you
finish writing it and hand it to me I
stay here until I get it from you then
we can all leave
okay all right so with that we'll close
the exact session on House Bill 1700
FN now I will open an exact session ex
session on House Bill
1036 and and given the fact that we had
a relatively robust discussion about
this Legislation during the work session
it seems to me that further work is
needed and so I'm going to
recess the exec session on House Bill
1036 until a future date so that more
work can be done on this bill so with
that I will close the exec session on
House Bill 1036 Recess Recess Recess
recessed I'm sorry not closed
recessed my
mistake now we can open a exec session
on House Bill 1078 relative to first
responder organization access to
wireless tower
collocation
uh need to fix the fix we need to fix
the Amendment as we discussed during the
course of the EXE the work session and I
don't think we can get that done today
so I think it's probably going to be
necessary to recess this executive
session as
well until we can get a modified version
of
this
amendment
so I recess the exec session on
1078 now I'll open an exact session on
House Bill 1465 FN relative to studies
of nuclear energy Energy Technologies
and as we had discussed earlier today
we're going to recess this one as well
because representative Harrington and
representative muns are working on a an
amendment representative Harrington
could you give us a brief outline of the
amendment you guys are going to well the
one of the problems was the uh the
original bill was very very encompassing
and sort of misin interpreted so we had
a fiscal note I think of over $120,000
for new employees and that was never the
intent here so we've been uh looking
with the with working with the
Department of energy on this and we're
going to try to come up with a position
that'll be like a nuclear coordinator
possibly uh in the combin it with the
office of offshore wind there's already
an established position there this will
allow somebody that's interested in
contacting the state of New Hampshire
and finding out about the status of
whatever anything nuclear is contact
person uh it'll also go ahead and clean
up the um bill of the or the leg
legislation that talks about atomic
energy commission and not NRC and a few
things like that and establishing that
position is one of the recommendations
out of the uh nuclear task for
commission that was just published if
you'll see I think it's I don't it's on
page 49 and it's option six or something
to establish that so we'd be
implementing that and I think it's a
good first step in the right direction
uh without spending a lot of extra money
that really wouldn't accomplish
anything Mr chair representative Ms yeah
and if if I could just add to that I
mean I I think every I agree with
everything that representative
Harrington has said I mean I think what
what I am also hoping we can do is is
clarify you know the reporting
requirements instead of having um
multiple state agencies reporting on on
nuclear activities have this coordinator
of nuclear policy be the one that's
responsible for producing that report
report and seeking input where
needed representative McGee there was
some there was some discussion this is
for you two guys there was some
discussion about uh figuring out which
pieces of 1644 might also be
incorporated in they were both on the
topic of nuclear are you guys reviewing
that or are you just doing something
separate I'm just of STI we have okay I
thought the chair had said something I
had requested that we consider doing
doing that um and I and you know I
hadn't had a chance to talk to
representative heritton about this but I
did talk with representative Vose and I
think my my thinking was that as part of
that coordinator's responsibilities to
to to report they could potentially
report on the things that representative
hering uh representative Vose was
interested in in
1465 yeah we can what if you just are we
listening in the back room
row
all right consider it when request made
thank
you okay thank you both any further
comment on
this seeing none I will recess the the
exec session on House Bill 1465
FN and then I will open an ex exact
session on House Bill 1472 FN relative
to relative to rebates of Energy
Efficiency funds for electric vehicles
and we're also going to recess this one
and we're going to recess this one for
the simple uh matter simple reason that
we don't have a sufficient uh attendance
here to support going forward with the
full exec
session but we do have a nice uh
amendment to consider now so we will go
forward with that at a future date uh as
well so
we will recess House Bill 1472 FN and
that concludes our work for CH we excuse
me we we have we have one missing member
and we're in an executive session so
we're we're not going to be able to vote
well the rules of the house say that
when a member is absent yeah that you're
allowed to replace said member provided
that he notifies you 25 24 hours in
advance of his absence and we learned an
hour ago that our member was not going
to be able to be here so we couldn't
arrange for a substitute and it is the
perogative of the chair to uh recess an
exact session at any time and so that's
what I've decided to
do I guess I point point of order yes
representative
question I guess what I'm struggling
with is that we did vote on a pre on
another bill in the same execu session
where the individual was
missing is that
inconsistent not as far as I'm concerned
an executive s is a finite uh session on
a particular
bill
so we will meet again next week but I
think we're only going to meet on
Tuesday we have completed all our public
hearings so the work we have left to do
is work sessions and executive sessions
so I think we can cut down to one day a
week from
here going forward until we finish all
our work what time do we meet on
Tuesday next Tuesday we can start at 9:
the following Tuesday we'll have to wait
until 10: every other Tuesday there's a
meeting in this room at from 9:00 to 10:
uh we ran into that issue this morning
and we'll run into it again in two weeks
so consider next Tuesday to to be a 9:00
start for work session and exec session
and the following Tuesday a 10:00 start
for work session and exec session and
with that we're done for today safe ride
home everyone and we'll see you on
Thursday